so let's jump right into it and here's
the solid model of our part that would
have been delivered by the customer no
dimensions we don't really care we're
going to look at a paper print copy this
here in just a second but before I get
into any kind of programming obviously I
want to study this part and figure out
exactly what it is that I want to do so
it looks fairly straightforward there'll
be some OD turning a couple of grooves
we've got a thread a drilled hole in the
center that's flat bottom a nice little
chamfer here it looks like we got a
radius on the outside a little counter
bore a couple of fill it's let's take a
look at the actual print there we go so
we've got a two inch 12 TPI thread it's
two and a half inch final OD so that
tells me right off the bat hey I'm gonna
need to start with stock that's greater
than that I don't you know you could use
two and a half inch diameter stock but
then this is this feature here will not
necessarily be concentric nor will it be
cleaned up unless we get really lucky
and our material comes in been oversized
so let's just plan on using 2 and 3/4
material and there I've got some
call-outs for those edge breaks I noted
a couple of call-outs for the width
they're not calling out an edge break
here on the groove but I'm still gonna
do it just because I like to be nice and
clean and now let's look at the ID print
looks like we got inch and a quarter
depth on this 750 diameter now it
doesn't say so on this print but I'm
going to assume just for the sake of
this class that this is not a tight
tolerance I'm just gonna pop that with a
3/4 inch flat bottom insert drill and be
happy with it they do call out an edge
break here so I will be tied to 50
thousandths by 45 degrees and then we've
got a counter bore on the outside
so now that I'm familiar with the part I
want to stop and think about the tools
that I want to incorporate in using this
so now I need a process idea and start
incorporating my tools from there so
here I have a blank piece of paper with
my process list I like to write this
down so that I can keep track of
features and just keep everything
straight in my head this is pretty
formal having this nice little process
list form it's not a bad thing to have
but certainly a piece of scratch paper
and a pencil will work just as well
before I start making this process list
I want to put a little asterisk on this
and I'm sure that some of you out there
are gonna say no no no this is how I
would do it or I would do it this way or
I would do it this way nothing is ever
incorrect if you get a good result so
feel free to to object and or do your
process in a different a different order
if you get a good part off the machine
at the end of the day you did it right
I'm just going to use what I know and
what I've learned in my experience as
being yep the right way for Charlie
there's always gonna be a right way for
you guys and hey knock yourself out
again if you get a good part at the end
of the day you won you're done so the
first thing I want to do is I'm going to
start easy I'm gonna face this part and
rough out the OD so on my process list
I'm just gonna tell it that the first
thing I want to do is a face
and to earn a face and turn process
number two I would imagine that now
would be a very good time to pop that ID
pop this little hole here and the reason
that I want to do this now instead of
you know doing all of the OD features
and then all of the ID features this is
a fairly big size I'm planning on using
a flat bottom inserted drill that's
already 750 or maybe slightly smaller so
that I can skim cut that with a boring
bar but that's still a large size and
that's a lot of tool pressure that could
possibly deform the material so if I had
a tight tolerance on one of these
features if I laid that incomplete
before I popped this hole then it could
move that dimension ever so slightly and
put me out of print so my strategy is
yeah let's rough the OD first and then
the second thing we're gonna do is the
second most aggressive which is drill
that that centerpiece out once I've got
that drill out of the way now I can go
in and now let's just pick a feature I
think I'm gonna do the groove I can do
this groove complete with my groove tool
and also I'm looking at this thread
relief and thinking sure if I use a dmg
turning insert 55 degree diamond I can
just drill run it down the backside of
that 45 degree chamfer and make this
whole groove with the the insert however
I think I will use the groove tool since
it's going to be in play anyway and just
make a little relief clear that stuff
out before the dmg comes in and finishes
that up so process number three will be
the groove process number four I can now
yeah let's just go in and do the
finishing turn
so that I can skim all of this out bring
these diameters into final then I will
run a run the threading tool and because
I know just from having done this half a
million times that if I finish and then
thread the threading tool is gonna roll
some burrs in and out so what I like to
do is after finish turn and thread I'll
come back in and do a little deeper in
action so what I'll do is I'll take that
DN mg and I'll run it up the face of
this to take care of any burrs that the
threading tool rolled forward and then I
will redo this back groove so that the
birds that were rolled this way will go
away however well wouldn't you know it I
think there's two R's in deburr what do
you think I'm gonna go ahead and put two
in there and if I'm wrong somebody's
gonna hit me that grammar nazis they'll
get me after i deburr that thread
there's a pretty good chance that that
tool will have rolled the burr back into
our thread which is more detrimental
than having just a burner hanging
outside the thread so I will also rerun
the threading tool through there just to
make sure that my lead is not buggered
after I've done my rethread let's go on
and do our looks like we're on to our
board now because we have finished all
of these diameters we've rolled the
groove we've threaded we've turned and
finished we've run this we've deburred
the thread so now we're on to our boring
cycle which will take care of this the
counterbore the sham fir and finish the
750 ID and now that's the completed part
right up to a cut off process so now I
have a rough idea of how I want to do
this again face and turn then we're
gonna drill then we'll lay in the
grooves
then we'll do a finish turn thread this
deburr the thread rethread it run the
boring bar and cut it off sound like a
winner I think we're doing well so far
so now that I have all my processes I'm
ready to create a tool list I have a
nice little form here again but of
course a piece of scratch paper is gonna
work just fine or you can just populate
your turret on the fly as you're doing
this there is no wrong way as long as
you get it right they get a good result
way how many times is Charlie gonna say
that today hmm
quite a few so let's start with station
and offset I want to have this
information ready to go not only is this
gonna help me when I'm setting up the
machine but also if I hand this job off
to someone who's gonna run the part
they'll also be able to just look at the
tool list and say oh hey my tool that's
in station 4 needs an adjustment which
offset is it boom right there so let's
just go through and make this happen
number one the rough turning process
let's go ahead and stick him in station
number 1 here
we're just gonna say that that's going
to be a C n mg
turning tool and let's give it a Oh
fifteen six nose radius this is going to
be important later on because I'm gonna
have to put the nose radius compensation
in my offset page but let's go ahead and
say alright see nmg fifteen six nose and
that's going to be offset one for
station number one now I like to when
I'm strategizing my turret layout I like
to keep all of the stick tools together
and all of the ID working tools the ones
that'll stick out from the face of the
turret together and grouped as far apart
as possible if you're using a three jaw
Chuck and you're trying to use a turning
tool right next to a drill or a boring
bar you can have some interference
issues we want to avoid that like the
plague
but station number two let's go ahead
and put our finish turning tool on there
so we're gonna call that a dmg finish
turn and let's also give him a 15-6 nose
radius just because I want to keep the
my finish nice and yeah there's no
feature on there that really requires a
eight thousand snows radius so that dmg
is going to be for offset too now for
station number three let's do our
threading tool again my strategy here is
not necessarily following the process
list but it is following the OD working
versus the ID working tools so this is
gonna be a single point thread oops
thread
sixty degree this is not a an ACME
thread so I'll just go ahead and call it
a 60 degree threading tool Oh thread
thread mm-hmm
pay attention thread sixty degree and
this is by the way we're gonna call this
the single point keep in mind there are
a million different threading tools
profile semi profile full profile
da-da-da-da-da we're just going to make
this a standard 60 degree single point
so we don't we don't need to incur the
wrath of the tooling manufacturers by
using their tools incorrectly ok station
number four let's go ahead and throw in
our ot groov tool and this one has to be
I'm going for a standard oh nine t35
because that will give me my big groove
that's in the front of the part let's
bring our print in here so that you can
see it it will do the groove that's in
the front of the part but it will also
give us the ability to do this one now
as you recall this groove has is larger
than O 93 but that's okay because I want
to use a can cycle to step the tool over
and make that full part so we'll call
that an O 93 five and now we can move on
to looks like we've got to turn we got a
groove we got to finish we got the
thread so now let's put our drill in
here but again I'm gonna skip a couple
of stations just so that I don't have
interference issues between my stick
tools and the excuse me the outside
tools so let's run all the way up to
number seven and this is going to be a
drill it's
oh let's make it a 7:45 insert drill and
it's offset number seven give it a
little space just so that we keep our
form looking nice and tidy and the last
thing we need is a boring bar let's make
that one half-inch because I want it to
be smaller than the drill size obviously
otherwise it's not gonna fit in my hole
and now all I'm down to do is the cutoff
tool now this is just a Charlie ISM the
fact that I put this all the way in
station 12 I've just found that it works
for me
that station one a roughing C nmg almost
never gets pulled out of the machine
you're gonna use it on just about every
part and the cutoff blade also rarely
comes out by making them twelve and one
it just works for me feel free to make
them one and two it's just this is
simply what works for me is on now I
automatically know that my cutoff is
gonna be in station number twelve so now
I have my tool list but I am gonna do
something a little special here on this
groov tool I want the ability to control
the width of this thing since I'm using
a single tool to plunge in if the width
of this groove isn't quite right if I
don't do something special right now I
will have no control over that I'll be
able to move the location by shifting
the Z offset of the tool but I won't be
able to widen or narrow this groove and
if it turns out it's a tight tolerance
that could be a deal-breaker so what I'm
gonna do on my OD groove tool right now
it's set to offset for I'm going to say
and
24 so I'm going to use two different
offsets for the same tool one for the
front edge of the tool one for the back
edge of the tool and you'll see when we
get into writing the program that we can
use that so now we have not only
adjustment for diameter and location but
also width of the groove very clever
little trick so now we have our tool
list our process list and we're ready to
move over to the machine alright so now
we're out at our machine and I'll go
ahead and move over to my
collision-avoidance to show you that
I've already populated my turret there
are my stick tools and my ID working
tools just as I strategized earlier I've
got plenty of clearance between these
stick tools versus these guys so this
will kind of illustrate what I was
talking about if this guy this drill
were right next to this stick tool while
using it I would have to worry about
this making contact with the jaws of my
my chuck all right here my parts
sticking out far enough so to where it
probably wouldn't be an issue but I just
want to be sure plus this same setup is
going to be used a little later on in a
more advanced class when I start doing
live tooling so this clearance will be a
little bit more of an issue down the
road like for right now I know that I'm
nice and safe I don't have to worry
about anything
I have already taken the time to touch
off my tools let's go over to our tool
data page I went ahead and populated all
of my offsets simply because a simulator
doesn't do a very good job of showing
the process of touching off tools we're
going to assume that we've already got
that down to a science so but what I do
have to do is I want to go through and I
want to populate my knows radiuses tool
number one we already know that that has
a 15-6 nose radius so here in my nose
radius compensation column I want to
make sure that I put in the exact radius
of the tool in both the X and the Z
column now some of the other lesser
machines only have one column for nose
radius but Akuma does not want to assume
that this nose radius wears evenly so it
gives you two different two different
columns for this nose radius make sure
you put the same value involved and the
strategy behind wanting to put in a nose
radius compensation versus making a
program with the that automatically
compensates for the tool nose radius is
what happens if the second time we set
this up we decide we don't have any
fifteen six nose radiuses in stock and
we have to use a no 31 - I want to be
able to use the same program without
having to modify it so I'm going to
allow the machine to compensate for the
nose radius so there's my my roughing
tool nose radius and I do have to
populate the P now for some of the
people that have been using fanuc
controls they use the letter T but it's
the same concept I just opened up the
manual just to illustrate what we're
talking about here we are expressing to
the Machine how the how the tool is
being held let me reduce that size a
little bit so you
can see what I'm talking about so this
is right out of the Akuma programming
manual for an L B style machine and
you'll notice that this is the imaginary
nose radius and that center point is the
theoretical gauging point so if I were
to touch off a tool I would get an X and
a Z and those two points will intersect
right at that Center
however the nose radius of the tool the
actual cutting point of the tool needs
to be compensated so there are nine
different P numbers that I could put in
here but for the sake of two axes
turning there really only are two that
I'll be using unless I start doing some
back turning which is not the case in
this demo so I have P 3 and as you can
tell by the way that's set up that will
be for a turning tool and the P 2 that
is for a boring bar so let's just worry
about those 2 right now since this is a
turning tool I want to make sure that my
P number over here is set to 3 because
that's a turning tool let's go ahead and
get rid of this guy and let's look at
number two which is also a 15 swoops I
don't think I changed it there we go
this is also a 15 6 by 15 6 it's also a
turning tool so it'll be p3 our number
for our OD groove tool there's uh
there's not really a significant nose
radius to worry about on this one and so
we'll just leave that blank I don't
really need to populate it if it's not
necessary and my single point the
writing tool obviously won't need it
either the last one number eight this
one is going to be a boring bar of eight
thousandths because I'm roughing and
finishing with the same tool so let's
make that a nice tight eight thousandths
and because this one is a boring bar not
a turning tool this will be p2 instead
of P three and again on our part off
tool the last tool being used it's not
necessary to have anything in there so
now my turret is populated and all of my
offsets have been calculated using a
touch center or a manual method but
we're all set and ready to go so now all
that's left to do is Mount our material
so let's go ahead and move this guy
around
there we have we're assuming we've got a
slug of two and three-quarter inch
material I have pocketed some jaws so
that this fits in nicely and there's
enough there's enough per blank that I
can make the part off at the width or
the overall length of the part just for
those of you that have a p300 control
I'd like to show you that we do have the
ability to see our blank in the graphics
so what I did is from my main operating
screen I went to my spindle one setup
tab and this blank ID gives me the
ability to display the material right
now it's grayed out
I can't enter anything here unless I
come down to above f6 and hit the edit
parameter and now it's lightened up and
I'm able to put in the outside diameter
of the part the outside length so my
slugs are 4 inches long 2 and 3/4
diameter and my programs zero position
Akuma likes to use the base of the part
as a datum so I have to express where my
program 0 point is as the same amount as
the program length that will move the
datum from the left side of the part to
the right side of the part sometimes I
like to make that a little bit shorter
let's guess give it ten thousands it's
not going to change the way the machine
behaves at all but what it is going to
do it will show in my graphics a piece
of the material coming off the face of
the part it's handy to see now if I say
okay it'll ask me do I save it yes I do
and now it creates a data model and I'm
all set and ready to go
time to start programming is anybody
gonna call me on something I missed
yeah I'm going to I have not set my zero
offset yet that is the point of the
material the face where my zero point is
going to be the end of the materials
with my datum so I need to express that
to the Machine there are several ways of
doing this and I'm going to talk about
two of the most popular right now the
first is if your tool setter is
calibrated with one of these tools any
one tool having AZ offset of zero if
that's the case then all we need to do
is to call up that tool so we'll put
tool number one in the cutting position
let me rotate this around so that we can
see whether or not it's there yep there
it is there's my tool number one it's in
the cutting position so now I can jog my
machine up to the face of the material
now because I'm using collision
avoidance I know that hey it says up you
you need to stop right there but with a
standard machine now that I've got the
tool number one the zero offset tool in
the cutting position I could light off
the spindle and make a facing cut across
the face of the part or touch the face
of the part if it's already a finished
datum either way I want to make sure I
don't move my Z from its current
position
now if I come back to my main operating
screen I'm still in the spindle one
setup tab and zero offset is currently
grayed out so by using f50 edit on and
off when I touch it it opens up unlocks
the zero offset and you notice that it
moved the cursor right to the z axis
because Akuma knows that this is the
main function that I'll be doing anytime
I move my zero offset the X zero should
remain at zero all the time if your
machine has been calibrated properly and
not bombed or knocked around so will
almost never adjust that guy right there
but my Z because the machine is
currently sitting right where it belongs
I can simply touch the calibrate button
and use a an integer that represents how
far from my current position is the Z
going to be in this case it's zero but
that's because I made a facing cut let's
say for instance I touched off of a one
inch side of a one to three block I
would say that now currently I am
sitting one inch away from my zero and
then pushing input will update the zero
offset
zero-input there's my new zero position
the second way that I alluded to of
doing this is if your tool setter has
not been calibrated with one of these
offsets as being zero if I touched all
of my tools and all of them have a value
here now I have to be a little a little
more careful with my process in MDI I'm
going to call up one tool any tool that
I want in this case let's use let's use
tool number two and because I am doing
something funky I want to make sure that
I call up that tool in MDI t whoops
let's go caps lock with that T 0 to 0 to
enter and cycle slam and now tool to
oops it didn't move let's boom there we
go now it's in position I'm coming back
over to my my main operating screen
because before we get too deep into this
process I want to make sure that I show
you guys the potential bites you in the
rear end that's going to occur here you
notice that here on the bottom of my
screen it shows that tool to and offset
to are in the cutting position and the
offset has been read let's go ahead and
look at my machine graphic right there
and tip it over to the side a bit there
we go
now I have to move the tool over to the
face of the part but here's where people
make a mistake right off the bat you
know that right now if I try to move my
machine
it won't go because I'm in MDI mode oh I
need to be in manual mode but watch what
happens to my tool and offset when I
switch over to manual it dumps the
offset so this is where you have to keep
your head in the right position T's zero
- zero - we'll do that again execute
that now it's in position don't go out
of MDI so how in the world do I move my
machine if I don't get out of M di Akuma
has this button right here some of you
use it some of you have never seen it
before this is awesome mid auto manual
if I turn that on now I can jog the
machine
even though I'm in MDI mode not manual
and my offsets still active so now I can
move over and make the process exactly
as you saw me do just a minute ago I
want to run to the front of the part
make a facing cut and then come to my
spindle one set up and do calibrate zero
input zero input and now my number is
good but before I ever hit the calibrate
I always make a point of going back to
the operating screen and make sure that
my offset is still active otherwise the
number that I get is going to be
incorrect by whatever value is in my
z-axis clears mud right I'm going to hit
reset now and now my offsets dumped
and I can get the tool back out of the
way
all right so now my work zero is set my
tool offsets are all set and now I
really am ready to go into the
programming stage so the first step we
want to do is find the program
operations button on our key panel and
press it and it will show us the machine
directory one by default we'll call it
MD one throughout the duration of this
class but just know that it stands for
the machine directory the primary number
one some of you that have advanced one
touch installed on your turning Center
you'll see these two tabs in the upper
right hand corner of the screen
one frenzy program and one is for IGF
for a ot graphic files I do suggest that
you want to make sure that if you do
have a ot installed that you touch the
NC program tab and make sure that we are
looking at the MD one they have another
name for the igf folder it's just
another directory and if you maintain
this ad zero as being all of your
graphics files for äôt and all of your
handwritten and C code and MD one by
keeping them separated like that it
makes life a little easier when you go
looking for a specific type of file so
I'm ready to create the file if you'll
notice the soft key f3 is listed as new
file by touching that I get a new option
down on my soft keys to create a
directory which is it's just a window
style folder so that I can categorize
the program if I want to you know I
could keep all of one customer in one
folder another and another
or by red numbers sky's the limit use it
however you like but what we're doing is
we're just creating a new NC program so
as soon as I touch the NC program key
now it comes up with the question what
is my file name going to be
I'm gonna call this oops better have
caps lock on I'm gonna call this class I
do not have to add the dot min it will
bring that in by default but I do want
to take this opportunity to show you a
mistake that's made by just about
everybody including myself at least once
in a while here is the name that I just
typed in class by default the file name
of a new file is a dot min if I fail to
hit the input key after typing in the
word class and I just get distracted by
this okay button above f7 when I hit it
it creates a program called a dot min
once I finish with this thing I won't be
able to find it because I thought I
named it class but the machine did not
accept the class input so it created a
dot min how do you get around that type
in your program name and then make sure
that you hit the input key and now you
notice that it took the word class from
my input buffer and put it into the file
name field up here now when I click on
OK it's created the program called md1
class that mistake gets made an awful
lot so let's just keep our eyes out for
it so now we have a blank screen where
we're ready to start programming I'm
going to click over to the look inside
my machine to show you that this
particular simulator has two spindles
which means I have to start the program
with a special special code I have to
specify which spindle I'm working on
G 140 that means left spindle right
spindle would be G 141 if you only have
a single spindle machine don't worry
about this code it's not something that
you need but if you don't put that in on
a standard 2 spindle machine it will
give you an alarm right off the bat
saying hey I don't know what you spindle
I'm working on you better specify it is
oh come on I put it on here somewhere
didn't I nope I omitted it from the G
code list simply because I figured we
were working on a two axis so it's not
listed on your on your form yet okay so
that is gonna be the very first line now
some of you that have some programming
experience with other brand controls
will go hey what happened to the usual
the usual stuff that I used to have to
type like oh one two three four or even
more aged than that what about the old %
or the the dollar sign or one of those
other characters that we used to have to
put in here's a little thing for you if
you are not communicating with an rs-232
wire then you don't need any of these
little preamble characters like the
percent or the dollar sign and since my
machine has USB and Ethernet capability
I'm never gonna use rs-232 I'm gonna
omit that how about the the O number
that's also not necessary other brands
of controls require that as the
identifier for the program that we're
currently working on but since we are
windows backed it already knows the name
of the program right here instead of
going by a number it is referred to as
class dot min so I don't need an own
number I can have it if I want to but
it's certainly not necessary I just
don't even look for those anymore
second line of care of code that we're
gonna put in here is a it's a graphics
related word clear and draw these are
also not required but since we're
writing this at the control and we don't
have the benefit of a cam system to show
us any errors we're gonna want to
utilize the 3d graphics function on our
machine I want to know what's gonna
happen long before the tool actually
touches metal so the clear and draw
statement that's in the header of this
program are gonna do exactly what they
say clear is going to erase the trace
lines and and the previous material
drawing in the 3d graphics and the word
draw is going to return the return the
material to its solid form the original
form that it had before before we
started cutting the the next code that I
want to do is right here on my list I
have to specify have to have to have to
specify to the Machine what is the
maximum spindle rpm that this set up is
capable of achieving you know
bunch of people out there are gonna go
wow heck it's a 4500 rpm spindle I want
to go 4500 rpm that's fine but as you
saw in my set up I have a three jaw
Chuck with a two and three-quarter inch
chunk of steel sitting in PI jaws in
fact they're not even PI jaws they're
just standard jaws so you know what I
really wanna don't want to be doing 4500
rpm
so I'm gonna utilize this code right
here g50 maximum spindle rpm
g50 and i'm going to put in the RPM that
is the maximum I feel comfortable with
this setup let's just say OS 20 750
depending on your setup yours will
obviously be different but hey that's
that's good enough for me
that that'll keep the keep me from
scaring the snot out of myself when this
thing ramps up to to go across center
line and the last thing I want to do in
the creation of the program is I want to
make sure I put in the home command I
want to send the turret from wherever it
is to a safe position I always put this
in the header of my program simply
because I have no way of knowing where
the turret was or is when I hit cycle
start so I just want to make sure that I
have a safety net no matter what happens
when I hit cycle start the first thing
that that occurs is the turret goes to a
safe position if you have programming
experience on some of the other controls
they have a couple of fancy little G
codes and special functions go to this
home position and yeah Akuma doesn't
even bother with making you learn
something new G 0 for rapid X 30 that's
close enough by specifying a travel
command in rapid mode that is greater
than the travel of the machine Akuma
just assumes that ok you mean go as far
as I can go and then stop
obviously the machine the size of the
one you see me working on here doesn't
have a full 30 inches of X travel but
the control looks at the the command and
says gotcha we're in rapid mode so I'll
go to my stops and then be done with it
and let's move Z at the same time so
that both of them will go to their full
position I only put Z 10 here even
though the Machine I'm working on has
more than 10 inches of travel only one
axis needs to be at the stop on a twin
spindle machine that is the x-axis and I
see you right here
but yeah okay that's going to position
it up against the stop and that's gonna
position the turret ten inches away from
the end of my material that should be
plenty safe for the turret to index
without actually clipping the material
one other thing that I'd like to point
out on this you notice I didn't put a
decimal place in here I did not bother
to say X 30 point Z 10 point it doesn't
it doesn't matter if I have the decimal
or not if I omit it Okuma assumes that
that's a whole number on some of the
other controls if you omit the decimal
it looks to the far right digit as being
the tenths digit and the second as being
the thousandths so on some controls that
command means to go to X 3 thousandths
geez that's that's confusing as all
get-out akuma no decimal all right it's
a whole number so I could say X 30 point
or X 30 and it means exactly the same
thing same thing with the Z and as long
as I'm talking about it I'd also like to
demonstrate that I don't have to have
spaces in between these I'm putting it
in there for the sake of this class but
if if I'm in a hurry or I you know just
don't want to reach down and hit the
spacebar I can cram these all together
the only stipulation is the only time
you have to have a space let me put it
that way is if the first statement ends
in a letter
whoa I can't even give you an example of
that the proper way if the first
statement ends in a number and the
second one starts with a letter then
we're fine
so x30 obviously that ends with a number
and z10 starts with the letter so it's
perfectly OK to back up and put those
two together all right
so now we've created the header of the
program and we are ready to move on and
start making some cuts
now this header that I wrote up above is
pretty generic I'll use the same header
for just about every program and I'll
throw in some extra codes like that G
140 if I've got two spindles or the G
code to command upper or lower turret if
I've got a multi turret machine but for
the most part that's all I will put in
for the header of the program I'd like
to take this opportunity to give a
little asterisk on here and let you know
that there really is no wrong way to
create a header same thing with the tool
call that we're about to make there's no
wrong way to do it but I have a set
pattern that I've memorized that I use
every time I'm writing a program by hand
so that I know I don't miss things
feel free to adopt what I'm doing but if
you already have a header in your mind
or you find one that that works for you
just stick with it that's my key there
is no wrong way of doing things as long
as you get a good result at the end of
the day and I'll probably say that about
20 more times before the end of this
class but seriously if you get a good
result there is no wrong way to do
things I get an awful lot of flack on my
youtube channel from people saying oh no
you shouldn't do it that way you should
do it this way fine everybody's got
their opinion but at the end of the day
if you made a part and it checks good
and the cause medically it's in
dimensionally it's in you
just u1 so don't stress over your
semantics being different from mine just
use what works and so that being said
I'm gonna show you what I use each and
every time I try to call a tool I like
to start with a sequence name and that's
an N the letter n is going to represent
a sequence name regardless of what
follows it the the digits that follow
the N number are simply an address that
you can use to find a certain tool or a
certain process or you know it's a
certain way of doing things some of the
other brands of control restrict you to
numbers after the N akuma doesn't do
that you can use letters and numbers
combined to make something that is
logical to you for instance we're about
to do a turning process so it's
perfectly okay for me to call this in
turn or in drill or in tap I can do
pretty much anything that makes sense to
me and that's really handy particularly
if I'm trying to put a sequence in
someone else's program for
troubleshooting if they haven't if they
haven't got a sequence right where I
need it I'll just add one that I know
won't confuse them like in here that's
my favorite one a GRE in here your you
have any four digits after the N to use
as a an address that makes sense to you
you can also incorporate numbers in
there but just know that in the sequence
once you've shifted two numbers you
can't go back two letters it is okay for
me to say n tap one but it's not okay
for me to say N one tap that will cause
problems so that being said what I like
to do is to use a number that
corresponds with the tool num
that I'm using on our process plan that
let me see I've got it right here there
it is
so the first item on our process plan is
the turning tool and from our tool list
we know that that tool is tool number
one so for our sequence we'll call it in
one and now I want to put in a series of
modal codes that are going to basically
put the machine in a status that I am
comfortable with and again I always use
the same the same sequence just so that
I don't miss something
the first that I always use is G zero
there's a couple of reasons for one just
before I started this sequence
I sent the turret home therefore the
first thing it's going to need to do in
order to get ready to cut something is
to position itself and G zero is the
rapid positioning call G zero will also
cancel any kind of drilling cycle any
kind of can cycle that might have been
active now kuma is really good about
cancelling these these cycles for us
when we hit reset but that's another
function of G zero that I like to have
in there the second code I always use is
to explain to the Machine which feed
mode I'm using if I come back over here
and I look at my gene ID 5 96 this is
explaining whether I'm using my feed
expressed as a distance per revolution
of the spindle or it is the feed per
minute inches per minute feed rate so
this being a two axis and we're not
doing any kind of milling because a two
axis does not imply milling I'm gonna
use G 95 so that the feed rate that I
express is going to be the actual chip
that the tool is pushing so now I have G
0 and G 95 the next code that I always
put in is G 97 which going back to our
little list here
G 97 is constant spindle speed command
which means whatever spindle rpm I ate
eight right here is exactly what the
machine is going to achieve rather than
G 96 which means the machine is going to
calculate where the tool tip is right
now and spin the RPM to achieve the
surface feet-per-minute that i've
specified in at G 96 Wow boy I hope he
explains that better and in five minutes
yeah sure I will G 97 and now I'm going
to put in a directional command and
s1000 just to get the spindle turning so
my first line in this modal cycle is an
one sequence rapid we're gonna use feed
per minute G 97 constant spindle speed
clockwise at a thousand rpm now my
spindle is turning the next thing I'm
going to do is I'm going to repeat that
sequence number same one right here this
is not something I do on older machines
because it's it's extra but on the
modern Akuma's there's a feature on it
called tool restart and that tool
restart will show you when where when we
go into the the verification of the
program once every once the program is
entirely written I'll show you how to
use the tool restart function and it
just makes life really easy because oh
hey I want to restart at the threading
tool we'll go to a page and say that's
where I want you to start we don't have
to remember any sequence numbers the
the whole reason I went into that big
explanation is because that tool restart
function requires you to have the N
number on the same line as the tool call
which is what I'm about to do so N 1
repeated and now I'm gonna call up tool
number 1 but that is not a complete
statement here because the T command
requires not only that we tell it what
tool number or turret position but it
also wants to know which offset we're
using so in 4-digit format the first two
digits are representing the physical
turret position the last two digits are
the X and Z offset that we're going to
use for that particular tool on a 2 on a
machine like this that's two axis
they're almost always going to be the
same it's there's no reason to
complicate it by saying something like
oh two one offset twenty one we are
going to do that just to show you how it
works a little later on but to a one
offset one that is what most of the
other brand lathe programmers know as
the tool call format but Okuma guys will
see an extra two digits whoa wait a
second now we've got six if you're using
the six digit format the first two
digits are the nose radius compensation
for that tool second two are the turret
position third two are the X and Z
offset so anytime you intend to use a
g-41 or g42 in your program make sure
that you've called up six digits not for
the machine will take either six or four
if you're not using g-41 but if you only
have four digit and you try to command
g-41 the machine will alarm out saying
hey i'm not going to assume that this is
the
this is the nose radius compensation
value that you want so now that I've
told it we're using tool number one now
is a really good time to put an operator
note in there to explain to the to the
operator what what this tool is CNM G
rough turn for those of you that aren't
really versed in CNC programming anytime
I put anything in between parentheses
the Machine doesn't read it skips it
right over it understands that that is
just a note for whoever's reading the
program in this case that's us so now I
know the tool one offset one nose radius
comp one is the CNM G rough turn last
thing for this line it's going to be an
m8 turn on the coolant that's kind of
important so now my spindle is turning
my tool is in the cutting position and
my coolant is on I'm ready to move from
where I am now all the way up in the
stop position down to an approach point
on the part some people I've seen will
write a program where they just zip
right into the cut I mean they'll rapid
from this point right down to the face
of the part and if you're in production
that's fine I knock yourself out however
it always scares the bejeebies out of me
because I want to see an intermediate
point something that the machine is
going to go to prior to touching
material so I have one last chance to
see whether or not my tool is gauged
properly so let's give that an X value
and we know that our material is 2.75 so
I'm gonna tell it to go to two point
eight five that is a diametrical value
so as I'm looking at the machine I'll
see that the tool should stop 50
thousandths radially from the OD of the
part and I also like to put in a hundred
thousandths in Z
so that it will position that tool
roughly you know a hundred thousandths
by 50 thousandths from the edge of my
rough material and so if I'm running in
single block I can let this thing come
down and park at that position and then
I know yeah okay my tool is gauged
properly if it goes beyond that point or
doesn't quite reach that point I have a
warning that hey I screwed something up
before the machine moves on and makes a
makes a mess
one thing I skipped over you notice that
I've been adding these little arrow down
here if you are a programmer of some of
the other controls you're probably
looking for the EOB key or end of block
key on those other controls when you
push that key the code types in a
semicolon one of you know those little
guys
Akuma doesn't use that we don't need to
by stroking the input key it'll
automatically put in this ASCII
character that means carriage return
line feed there is no arrow key on your
machine but that enter button or the
input button will generate that code for
you and when you're done typing just
push input alright one last piece of
information that I want to use for the
tool call in this particular case we're
doing a turning tool and I haven't
really specified the material but I'm
gonna call it 41 40 just to say I did I
don't want to get into splitting hairs
about oh your feeds and speeds are wrong
441 40 or this no no no we're not we're
not gonna try to deal with feasibility
here we're just going to say hey this is
steel and because this is steel I do not
want the tool to
work harder than it has to remember we
talked about this G 97 right here which
turns on the spindle at a thousand rpm
and it'll just leave it there that's all
well and good if I were drilling but in
this case the tool as it gets closer to
the center of rotation is going to
contact material at a slower surface
feet per minute than it would if it were
further out the machine knows that
that's not good for a tool so it gives
us a cycle where we can specify a
surface feet per minute and it will
change the RPM for us in order to
maintain that surface footage based on
where the tool tip is it's doing the
calculation for us it's really cool so
in my case G 96 now is constant surface
speed and I want to put in an S and
specify what the manufacturers
recommendation is for this tool in this
material so 4140 for this tool let's
just say is 650 surface feet per minute
so now the machine will have shifted
from constant spindle a thousand rpm to
constant surface 650 and that with the
exception of adding or subtracting this
G 96 is the format that I'll be using
for every one of my tool calls and I
just haven't memorized so that I can
spit that stuff out in my sleep now
we're ready to move on to physical
cutting so let's swing our print back in
here take a look at we decided so our
first process in just about every part I
do is to run the roughing tool across
the face of the part to establish a
datum we're gonna be drilling here in a
few minutes and if this happened to be a
soft cut piece of material or something
ugly I don't want to I don't want to try
to drill or put some kind of fragile
tool on a rough surface
so I'm going to swing my my roughing
tool from the position where it is now
right about where you see my cursor and
the first thing I want to do is move to
the face of the part and then I will
feed down over the center line pull it
back out and return to that position so
let's just do that one step at a time we
already know there were a hundred
thousandths away from the part at above
the material diameter so the first thing
I'm going to do is to say I'm in Rapid
mode right now so I'm gonna move let's
just say mm off the face of the part
since this is a roughing tool I do want
my finish tool to take a little bit of
material but the Z in general does not
like to take a lot of material so we'll
just give it two thousandths and be
happy with that now that was a rapid
positioning move which was fine because
I'm up above the material but now I want
to go into feed mode before I move
things down across the face so g1 taken
right from my g-code list right there
linear positioning or interpolating so
now I'm going to g1 and I want to move
down in x over the center line so that I
don't leave any abnormality right in the
center of the part so let's specify that
this is moving in the x-axis and we'll
go - since we know the center of the
part is zero we want to go beyond that
by at least the radius of the tool but
in my case I usually do a little more
than twice the radius just to make sure
that everything's cleaned up it's gone
over over the center line so now I've
moved in quickly fed down I haven't
specified a feed rate yet so let's go
ahead and give it I'll say six
thousandths that should be enough to not
abuse the tool but definitely I don't
want to spend a lot of time on this cut
because it's just a roughing cut
now I've moved beyond the center line
the next thing I want to do is get away
from the material now I'm doing this in
feed mode mainly because my machine tool
here has collision avoidance software
and it does not like to move to rapid
mode when you are touching material so I
just fed back out I can do that extra
fast since we're not cutting anything
but now I've moved back out to a hundred
thousand so nice clearance plane above
my material now I can shift back into
the rapid mode and go back to my two
point eight five clearance diameter so
now I've just zipped across the face
move back out and cleared the part let's
go ahead and verify that you know I've
already made motions so let's let's
let's go start our graphic verification
process before I get out of this program
though I'm gonna want to put in one more
code that represents end of program
obviously I've got a lot more to do but
I anytime I want to run this program I
have to have an m2 or m3 to signify to
the Machine that that's the end of the
program and I want you to stop
everything all right
so let's go ahead and I'm going to push
the quit stop button here because I've
made a change to my program it says hey
I just did some editing do you want to
save it yes I do now if I let's get rid
of my print here so I can see my keypad
I'm going to go to my automatic mode
which takes me right to my main
operating screen now this isn't going to
help me any to view the the process so
I'm gonna look at my special functions
graphics page if you have an older
control you'll see right on the front
here a display change button on the
newer P 300 a controls you'll have to
arrow over one time but then you'll find
display change
and by touching that I get a window that
pops up that shows me all of the
different available screens that I can
look at some of you may see an
abbreviated version of this screen I
have the ability to filter out ones that
I'm not using let's show you how to do
that very quickly here if I with this
window up if I push the arrow over
button f1 will change into a value of
menu change by touching that it allows
me to say yeah I don't want to see that
I don't want to see that I don't want to
see that I do the one I do want is
animated simulation so now I've
abbreviated my list somewhat but I just
want to pick up animated simulation and
then close this outer window there's my
graphics and now I'm just Oh before I do
anything else I also want to make sure
that the machine can't move obviously it
would be very bad at this point since I
haven't proven anything if the machine
physically you know indexed tool number
one and went down and made a facing cut
I'm not ready for that yet so what I'm
gonna do is I'm going to basically build
a wall in between the computer and the
machine by using this button right here
machine lock on your keypad you'll
notice that machine lock is one of the
few that's white all of the other
membrane panel buttons are a different
color a white button indicates that you
must press and hold the il or interlock
release button to engage the specific
button that you're trying to access so I
push and hold the interlock release
button and then I push machine lock and
now the computer is separated from the
machine and I will be able to see the
graphics run but the machine itself
won't run so let's go ahead and turn on
single block so that I can talk while
I'm doing this it means that every time
I hit the green button it's gonna
execute one line of code and one more
thing I want to look at in my graphics
it's showing me distance to go and feed
rates and velocity and cutting
but it's not showing me the program I
want the program so I look down here and
the value of soft key f5 is program on
and off if I touch that now I get to see
my program every time I push cycle start
we're gonna see it go through one more
line of code there's the first one now
it cleared out the previous graphics we
didn't have any so you didn't see him go
push green one more time and now it drew
my material for me dynamite and touch it
again now the RPM limit has been engaged
the machine has gone all the way home
and in my case a collision block let me
fix that okay I fixed it behind the
scenes because well doggone it you guys
don't need to worry about my simulator
thing
okay so let's turn back him on my
program and I hit cycle slam there
cleared the old graphics drew the new
graphics went home now on this line it
took my modal codes and started the
spindle rotating and it called up tool
number one wrapping it to my clearance
plane and now it's going to shift into
constant surface speed move to z mm off
the face of the part and now I'm going
to see a facing cut go down the front of
the part let's go ahead and crank up my
my feed rate and my spindle rpm to make
it go faster next move it's going to
move to a hundred thousand suwaordo
might now one thing I didn't show you is
that I probably should have but before I
go and run this I should the main
program operate program select and pick
up the program that I was running there
it is
if you we're gonna see in just a minute
a way to compress that operation with
finishing our editing function but I
just wanted to get that out of the way
now let's run through it look at what I
did
I'm usable directory how come nobody
busted me for this can you tell what at
what mistake I made G zero two point
eight five there's something missing
there get back in and edit my program
there it is right there G zero two point
85 in what axis I forgot to put the X in
there yeah now it should be all better
but now that I brought that up let me
show you that feature that I was just
talking about I made an edit change
previously I used the quit stop function
if you arrow over one time and use
select and quit instead of just saving
the program it also relocate reloaded
into the OS p the modified program so
now if I run it again let's take off
single block and just let it go Zoop
there's my X that caused the problem
previously chip done all right so now
we've graphically verified that our
facing cut is functional and we're ready
to move on to the next item now as I was
doing this cycle or this this cut that
tool was only pushing a few thousandths
off the face of the part it was not an
extreme amount probably a maximum of 20
to 30 thousandths which the tool can
handle without any kind of issue however
my next cut is going to be roughing out
the periphery the OD of this part and
that is not a true statement when I'm
bringing at bringing the tool across the
face sure up here there's a minimum
amount of material coming off but as I
get here there's more material more
material here
so I have to do something other than
just trace the tool over the OD of the
part sure it may work for some some
parts but it certainly is not the case
for this one as this diameter the 1.5 is
well below the 2.7 50 that the material
measures to start and that's just too
much for my tool to push so I need some
I need some assistance for mikuma on
this what we're going to do is utilize a
canned cycle I'm sure you've heard that
eat that phrase used a whole bunch but
let's explain what a canned cycle is if
I would like oh one of my kids to go get
me a glass of water I can just say hey
I'm thirsty will you please go get me a
glass of water I don't have to tell them
I would like you to pause the ps3 get up
off the couch walk across the kitchen
floor enter the kitchen open the open
the cupboard pull out a glass put it
under the faucet lift the faucet data
that it added a tap I'm able to say
simply hey I'm thirsty would you please
get me a glass of water and I can trust
that the process is already clear in
their brain and just a few parameters
that I give them water glass thirsty and
they can fill in the rest well it's the
same thing with the machine tool with a
canned cycle that's the equivalent of
asking the machine hey I'd like you to
do something and I'd like you to do it
with these parameters and go so the
canned cycle for doing roughing is g85
I've opened up the g85 cycle in the
document package and I have my step by
step instructions here an example of
utilizing the instructions and also the
page of the manual that shows exactly
how what parameters the can cycles
looking for so let's go ahead and open
up our program again we're going to push
the program operations button and it
will take us back to the machine
directory one our class dot min is
still highlighted and it's blinking
signifying it's the active program by
touching edit it will open up that
program and will position the cursor
right after the facing move that we just
made now we can come over here to our
roughing can cycle document and let's
make sure that all of the conditions for
utilizing this have been satisfied move
tool to clearance plane that was done to
right there at the previous before the
facing cut put tool in cutting position
there it is spindle commands we know we
did that coolant move part to clearance
plane and how the part the tool was
moved to the clearance plane here but
then we did a bunch of stuff moving the
tool around the face of the part so I
want to make sure that I have delivered
the part back to that or the tool back
to the part clearance plane X 2.85 we
know that's above the diameter of the
stock and z point one in front of the
face of the stock so I'm happy and it
has satisfied the move tool two part
clearance plane number six called the
cycle with cutting specifications and
roughing speed
okay I'm gonna skip a little space there
you don't have to I'm just doing that in
order to keep the keep everything
understandable so let's call the cutting
cycle which we know is g85 that's also
on my g code list right there g85 bar
roughing cycle so there's my g 85 and
now i have to specify a few parameters
the first of which is a sequence that is
where the first block of the contour is
in other words the machine needs to know
where am i defining the shape of the
finished part and that's going to be
defined by a sequence and as you notice
right out of the manual they like to use
n 80 so I'm a big fan of that in
tea the reason I do that is because I've
been using a sequence number at the
beginning of a tool so I like to do
something a little differently for shape
definition and that's pretty much why
Akuma created this format 30 odd years
ago that stands for sequence a turret so
if you have a more complicated machine
you might see in bTW for the B turret
but we only have one turret on this
machine so an 80 is all we'll ever see
that's not that could be enough
information
if I were confident I was only gonna do
one roughing cycle in this part I'm not
I am not confident at all I have a
roughing turning here I'm gonna have a
roughing boring cycle a little later on
so let's go ahead and put a designation
a number designation on here this is the
n a turret first can cycle definition
first shape definition n 8001 and now
let's come back up here and look at okay
we did the call cycle with cutting
specifications I am not done just by
saying hey I'm gonna rough and this is
my shape or this is where the shape is
defined I need to put some parameters in
here and those parameters are listed on
this page and while the manual puts them
in this specific order I can use any
order I want as long as I include all of
the mandatory information just about
everything you see here is mandatory
information it needs to know a depth of
cut a feed rate and the stock removal
and finish turning cycle what does that
mean that's the finish allowance in X
and the finish allowance in Z this
little code right at the end the g84 is
change of rough conditions that's
optional this is only necessary if in
the middle of the roughing cycle I want
to change my cut conditions like the
feed rate or the the speed or it's it's
advanced stuff
that I'm not using right now so we're
will not even worry about that let's
just worry about the mandatory
information
I don't follow this this letter sequence
because I'm used to doing things a
certain way and doggone it this is just
how I do it
you can put whatever you want in here
but I always start with the U or the X
finish allowance this is the amount of
material that's going to be left on the
x-axis of the part during the roughing
cycle and then we've got one for W
that's the z-axis finish allowance and
then we're gonna want a depth of cut
whoops that's a little short that is how
much the maximum material that will be
pushed by the tool is allocated right
here three hundred thousandths is the
maximum that the tool is going to be
pushing as it moves up the axis now
there may be a lighter cut if say for
instance the that the cut amount doesn't
come out even but it will never exceed
three hundred thousandths and my last is
the feed rate and the feed rate that I
put in here just as it says right here
is in the rough turning cycle only this
tool the roughing tool is going to be
tied to that F point zero one two I'm
able to specify feed rates in my shape
definition that will only apply to the
finish tool and we will do that here
momentarily let's get rid of that guy
and bring back up our print so that we
can go through and now we need to define
the shape of our part as specified right
here so the first line and 8001 whoops
make that active Charlie and 8001 I put
this in here making sure that it matches
the code in the call up
just so you know na t1 is different than
in 8001 make sure that these match
exactly just as a footnote it's not
required that I put the shape definition
in 8001 right after this g85 line I can
put it anywhere in the program but
because it makes the most sense to me
this g85 and 8001 call will be right
before the actual shape definition the
only other piece of information that we
want to put on the first line of our
shape definition is the type of cut that
we're using in our case it's GA t1 and a
GA t1 is the shape pattern moving
cutting in the z axis
sort of like you see the cursor moving
right here it'll make the cuts in Z and
the positioning moves will be in X if I
wanted to do the opposite where the
cutting motion is in x-axis and the
positioning is in Z that would be g82
but in general I use the Chi 81 most
often simply because I want to keep the
tool in the cut the longest I don't want
the wasted moves to be the majority of
the cut path I want the physical cutting
going on if I were facing a disc that
would be more efficient to use g82 but
in this case GA t1 is just fine and
that's the end of the first line of our
shape definition so let's start and the
very first move that we want is to move
from where the tool is now that's right
about here in our clearance plane and we
want to wrap it down in x2 where we're
in position to start our cutting profile
and this is a mistake that an awful lot
of people make they need you need to
understand that this first motion is how
the computer is going to decide whether
we're doing an ID or an OD roughing
cycle if my rapid is an X plus
then it assumes we're doing an ID cycle
if the rapid is an ex- it assumes were
OD and that's important because it needs
to know which side of the material to
leave this finish allowance that's
critical so we are going to make a g0
motion and we're gonna go to X we're
just gonna say one point oh I don't need
to go all the way down the centerline
because I know I've got a counterbore in
here that's like an inch and a quarter
so as long as my tool is down below
where that material will be residing -
I'm in good shape so now the tool is
sitting right about here I'm ready to
kick in to feed mode G one and move to
the face of the part but this is also a
very good time to put in my tool nose
radius compensation so at the risk of
over explaining the the concept here we
have 25 thousandths radius called out in
the print if I were to just program 25
thousandths and the Machine swung its
axes to make a 25,000 oh that there's a
15-6 nose radius on the tool so we would
have significantly less of a radius on
our part and it would be just a pain if
we had to do the math every time to say
oh okay twenty-five thousand snows
radius plus 15 six and that's a
diametrical value at oh wow that's way
too confusing let the machine do the
thinking for me by adding this g42 nose
radius compensation for OD it will
automatically compensate for the tool
nose radius to cut exactly twenty five
thousand snows and then we're going to
move to Z zero and since we're not
cutting anything let's go with a nice
high feed rate in this case six
thousandths now the tool is sitting
right here at the face of the part we're
ready to make a motion up and swing this
radius
so we know that a straight-line move is
g1 we established that right here and an
arc move clockwise would be g2 counter
clockwise would gbg3 and I have to
consider this radius right here so if I
didn't have Akuma helping me out I would
have to move in a straight line to where
this radius starts and then shift from G
1 2 G 3 to throw the radius in there but
wow that's a lot of math I'd have to
take the 1.5 minus the radius minus a
radius on the other side terminate that
oh what a pain in the butt let's go back
over to our G code process and look up
automatic sharing automatic corner
rounding G 76 G 75 that's gonna help me
out greatly to use this all I need to do
is tell it that I'm going to utilize the
corner rounding or the auto corner
rounding cycle which is G 76 now instead
of doing a bunch of math I'm simply
gonna tell the Machine what's the final
diameter that I'm going to in this case
it's x 1.5 now I need to tell it before
you get to that 1.5 I want you to swing
that radius and that value is an L it's
for the radius or the Sham 4 depending
on whether your G 75 or 76 there will
always be an L value that just
represents how big is the radius or the
Sham fer the next thing we have to do is
decide whether the L value is a negative
or positive value and the way I explain
this to customers on site is that a
shaffer or a radius is a two axis move
has to be and that's the only way you
can make a share for radius is to move
two axes at the same time so one of
those two axes has been named in my
statement there it is x one of those
axes is unnamed in this case Z so my
question is which direction do I want
this is the
unnamed axis Z to move to properly swing
this radius if I come up here and I move
swing the radius
notice that the Z or the unnamed axis is
moving in the minus direction which
means that my L is going to be negative
L minus 0.025 will now swing a z axis
negative 25 thousandths radius before it
gets to the 1.5 inch diameter and we'll
give that a feed rate again the roughing
is going to ignore these feeds in here
this is just for the finishing tool so
now we have moved up to our major
diameter we've swung the radius and
we're parked right here the corner
radius and corner chamfering automatic
cycles are just dynamite I use them all
the time but here are two rules that you
have to observe when you're using this
first off you have to have a straight
line at least one ten thousandth of an
inch before you swing the radius it has
to make a straight line so let's use an
example of what you can't do we already
know that this is a 1.5 diameter minus
25 thousand so on this side minus 25
thousands on this side so one 450 is
where this radius starts I could not
command the machine to go to one 450 and
then try to tell it to swing a one and a
half inch radius at L minus o 2 5
because it would not have enough space
to make that one tenth of straight-line
move it would be just fine if I made
this one point four 49 and then this to
one point five but I give it enough
motion so that I can just look up there
glance at it and say oh yeah there's
plenty of motion the second rule is the
exact same thing on the exit of the arc
I know that this is Z zero so when the
arc terminates it'll be at Z minus 0.025
I have to have a straight line after
this radius that goes further down than
the then where the radius terminates so
it knows how to mathematically compute
this which works just fine for me
because my straight line move is gonna
go all the way down to minus 1/2 inch
and let's pump that back up notice that
I decrease my feed rate as I'm going
around two axis moves just to minimize
the record player look however if it's a
single axis move I can just halt on the
thing and I'll still have a nice surface
finish so now I've zipped down to this
corner right here with that Z minus 0.5
move and I'm ready to hey move up to
this diameter and there's a chamfer so
this time we'll use G 75 the Shaffer
move and my final x diameter is the
major of this thread or X 1 point 9 9 5
and L again my unnamed axis it's not X
because X is named so Z is gonna move in
the minus direction so L minus 0.075 and
we'll give that the slow feed rate again
because it's the 2 axis type motion now
I'm ready to make my z move and it looks
like Z minus 1 point 2 5 0 will take us
down to this point right here and now
I'm ready to make this chamfer I cannot
use the G 75 cycle because as I just
explained in length I don't have any
motion to make a straight line X before
the start of this shampoo so I will just
say move from X 1 point 5 1 0 and z
oops did I make that mistake I sure as
heck did that's a 2.5 x x 2.5 and the Z
is minus one point five one zero and
let's make that at my reduced feed rate
all right that puts us at this point now
I need to finish off the part by saying
Z minus now if I just said two point
five that would in theory mathematically
finish the part but it would leave a
radius for the tool oh right here at the
end plus I'm gonna part this thing off
so I would just as soon have the
roughing in the finishing tool continue
on past this two point five margin by
the width of the part off blade and then
I'm gonna add another twenty thousand
source o to it so that I don't risk
running my part off blade into a wall of
trash material back here so let's just
say we're gonna move to Z minus two oops
two point six forty five my part off
plates an eight inch so that would be to
625 minimum and then add twenty
thousands to that just for a nice little
clearance and now my tool is all the way
over here the part is finished or the
the roughing profile is finished but I'm
not through with the semantics of my
canned cycle I don't want to terminate
down here because there's going to be a
rapid move when the the part finishes
back to my original point and I also
have to consider that my g42 my nose
radius compensation is still active
right now I want to make sure that I
cancel that so my thing I don't like to
see two axis moves when it's retracting
turning tool is not such a big deal but
when you see a two axis move on a boring
bar that's coming out of the middle of
your part it can scare the snot out of
you so just for protocol I always make
sure that my final X move is going to
put me back
at the clearance plain where I started
so let's throw in the G 42 cancel my G
42 and X that guy right there two point
eight five that way I know that it's
going to be a one axis move to return to
my clearance plane rather than a two
axis move that looks like my entire
shape profile so now I can simply
utilize the G code to express the end of
the definition of the shape which is G
80 now G 81 started it G 80 completed it
there is the definition of my profile my
tools still gonna be sitting here at
half-mast I need to ask myself am I done
with this tool yeah I believe I am so
let's go ahead and send it home and put
the machine in a condition where we
could open the door if we needed to to
inspect the the results of this cut so
we will go into rapid mode and identical
to our clearance move up here we're
going to say G 0 X 30 Z 10 and then I'm
gonna put in my the conditional operator
stop I'm sure some of you already know
this but let's repeat it just in case an
m1 when the computer is running the
program it encounters m1 it'll look up
at your key panel and if this optional
stop button is highlighted if it's
turned on the little LED here is turned
on it treats that m1 as a stop sign and
it will stop until somebody comes up and
either resets the program or hits cycle
slam and allows you to continue on if
that light is off as it is now it'll
blow through that m1 as if it were a
yellow light in the state of California
they just blow through it so that's our
optional stop gives us an opportunity to
inspect the part during prove out but
once we're in production we can just
barrel on through it so I'm going to
save the program and run it through the
graphics again this time I'm going to
arrow over and utilize selected
quit it asks if I want to save it yes I
do now it not only saved the program but
it also reloaded it so that when I push
the cycle slam button the the updated
program is the one that's gonna run I'm
still in machine lock and my rapid I'm
sorry my feed rate and spindle are
cranked up so that we can see this thing
run my program is showing so by hitting
the green button it just starts running
in graphics not the actual machine now
we're in our g85 cycle I didn't tell it
make this pass make this pass make this
pass I simply defined the shape and look
at it go it's doing exactly what I hoped
it would do which is rough out my
profile leaving 10 thousandths in the X
and mm in the Z for a finished pass at a
later date and then it went home and
stopped that pretty much looks like the
rough shape of what we wanted to make
doesn't it I think we're doing pretty
well so now let's go back to our process
list and look at what we have next we
did our turn we're ready to do a
drilling cycle we're gonna pop the
center out of this part there's my ID
print and it looks like we're going to
knock a 3/4 inch hole inch and a quarter
deep let's leave that up for a second so
that we can then go over to our G code
list and there's our face grooving cycle
which okay it can also be used as a
drilling cycle which is what we're gonna
do
let's go ahead and pop up our G 74 cycle
document and there's our list of what to
do plus the page in the book that
expresses what's going to happen and
what's required now there's a bunch of
extra information in this that we're not
going to use during this particular
cycle but we will cover it when we do
the G 73 version of this which turns
this entire process 90 degrees and does
a group
cycle let's go ahead and go back to our
program by touching the program
operations button we're still active
here so edit and we will cursor down to
the end of our tool call and we're ready
to follow along with the process that we
have right here move tool to clearance
plan clip tool in cutting position
well I could retype all of this
information because that's what this is
moving the tool to clearance and calling
of a tool or I can use some of the fancy
OSP assistants like the copy and paste
function by positioning the cursor on
the first line that I want to copy I can
touch F one copy and it turns the cursor
into a highlighted block we'll move down
here I'm not going to pick up the G 96
because as you know that's constant
surface speed and I want a constant
spindle speed for this drill a drill
doesn't have a surface footage
calculation since the X offset is 0 now
by touching the input key that highlight
block went away but this information is
on the clipboard in the windows
background so now I'll just position the
cursor where I want the information to
be pasted and touch paste obviously I
have to change a few things here like
this is no longer tool number one so it
won't be in one and my locations are
incorrect but I still have some basic
basic structure we're gonna use tool
number seven for this we're still going
to maintain all of this modal
information but let's go ahead and fire
the spindle to right where we want it to
right where we want it to be spinning
for this drill 1750 is roughly 350
surface footage for a 3/4 inch drill and
so that's what we'll use and we'll
change this sequence number to match and
instead of being tool one offset one
nose comp one this is tool seven offset
seven and since we're not using any nose
radius compensation I
don't need the first two digits I can
have them in there if I need that
continuity but it gives me a hint as to
whether or not I'm using those radius
compensation if I omit it when I don't
need it
and now this is no longer CNM G ruff
this is now a point 747 insert drill I I
said it was 747 it might be 750 doesn't
matter I'm gonna use the boring bar to
finish up that diameter anyway so yeah
something close to that and I turned on
the cool it in the previous tool I went
to X 2.85 but in this case I want to go
to X zero because that's where this tool
is measured it's gauged at the
centerline of rotation to the center of
the drill so put it at X 0 and Z point 1
sometimes because drills are a little
scary and I don't want to bump this
thing into the face of the part I might
go so far as to have it a little further
out from the face of the part but that's
gonna take a little bit more time to
work in the cut it's just gonna save me
a panic factor when I am when I'm
proving that my gauging is correct let's
leave it there for now just to say I did
now we're ready to follow along our list
moved apart clearance plane and call the
cycle referring to the feature so the
cycle is of course G 74 and I need to
put in my parameters for how to use this
particular cycle where is the X
obviously that's at X 0 and the Z is
representative of the bottom of the hole
that's what it says right here Z
coordinate of target point so that's
where I want to finish this guy and
let's find my print which we know is Z
minus 1 point 2 5 so Z minus 1 point 2 5
here's a little footnote for you even
though we're at X I repeated the x value
in the can cycle you have to do that
otherwise the machine generates an alarm
and says hey
I don't know if you are trying to shift
off of the X centerline and make this
hole larger this can cycle gives you the
ability like you see in this example
right here to make multiple pecks
at different X values so that you could
make a whole larger you do that with a
boring bar if you wanted to peck a peck
abour so by repeating where we are as to
where we want to terminate it knows
we're not doing this little step over
thing so now I have my X and I have my Z
I need a depth of cut here which is D
and let's give this a peck amount of
well let's go eighth of an inch
now you notice on my example here it's
showing that this drill is pecking in by
the D amount and then it's doing this
little short retract that means that
currently this is set to a short retract
chipbreaker style cycle if I want the
drill to come out of the hole I need to
add a value of L see the L right there
it's specifying that hey I want you to
make short retracts until you reach the
L value then I want you to come all the
way out of the hole wrap it back in and
continue on with your D value until once
again you reach L and do another full
retract so if I wanted to retract the
drill after every Peck I could make the
L and the D match all right that makes
sense but if my material is such that I
don't need to get cool it down on that
tip after every pack I could whoops not
no no two decimals doggone it I could
make my full retract value a different a
greater value than the D so it'll do
exactly what you see here short pack
short pack short pack full pack short
pack short pack short pack full pack and
on until it reaches the target value of
z minus one point two five wow that's
kind of neat
use that quite a bit now we need a feed
rate for the drilling cycle in this case
we're gonna go three thousands per
revolution
keep in mind there are two inserts so
each inserts only going to be pushing
half of that but that's just a footnote
it doesn't really relate to our
programming much and now we've completed
our pecking cycle and I'm ready to get
the drill
send the drill home now again working on
ideas I mentioned in the previous
segment I don't like to make two axis
moves when I'm working on the ID it
scares me I never know if the X is going
to wrap it into the side of the part and
this is a perfect example I know full
well that gee 74 is going to after it
reaches the Z target value it's going to
return to this position I don't always
trust it so by force a habit I always
put in a rapid move to get me the heck
away from the part and considering that
those two are exactly the same I may
even go so far as to say hey get a
little further away from the part just
so that during prove out I am
comfortable with what's going on it's
only gonna add a couple of milliseconds
to your cycle time but it will save on
your nerves which you know my age I need
that I'm clear the hole I'm ready to
repeat the go home and optional stop so
let's go g0 I don't have to repeat that
because it's in g0 modal mode from the
previous line but hey whatever X 30 Z 10
and an m1 let's go see what happens once
again I'm gonna do my select and quit do
I want to save yes I do and we'll get
rid of all that information go back to
my automatic mode turn on my program
okay so once again I'm gonna run this
from the very beginning then on the next
tool I'll show you how to skip over some
of this extra stuff but this gives me a
chance to to flap my gums a little more
as the machine is repeating what it was
previously doing
there's our roughing can cycle and you
notice that even the graphics because we
have an increased feed rate they're
showing this as a rough finish a rough
surface finish it's really neat when we
go and kick down to a shorter smaller
finish allowance you're gonna see that
that clean up
there's our drill doing short retracts
until it reaches a depth of increments
of half an inch and then it retracts and
we're out of there how cool is that now
one more thing I'm gonna do to show you
a feature of the graphics I can turn off
the solid and show just the lines of
what's going on or as I prefer I just
see the see the solid material if that
drill had taken off at an angle I'd
probably see an abnormality here so I'm
confident that I did it right there's a
few other graphics features that we're
gonna cover it a little bit but for
right now that's that's cool we did our
drill we did our rough we're ready to
move on to the next process so somebody
go ahead and ask what is the next
process Charlie well I'm glad you asked
let's call the park wow I'm getting
punchy aren't I let's call up our
process list and we did our turn we did
our drill so we're on to the groove
cycle excellent let's see if we've got a
groove cycle here that we can call up
there it is lost it there for a second
there's our OD ID grooving cycle and the
page from the manual looks an awful lot
like precisely what we did with the G 74
but this time we're going to be pecking
in the x-axis instead of the z-axis
clear enough all right let's get rid of
some of this noise and we will go back
into our program edit now I have been
utilizing this little scroll bar on the
right side of the screen which is easy
to do on a PC but on your machine tool
it's kind of difficult to
touch this bar and with your finger and
get it to scroll up and down it's not
difficult when the program is brand new
but as this program gets longer that bar
gets shorter it's more difficult to
catch so let me show you a couple of
interesting things if you have the p300
a control you'll be able to scroll just
like you would on your your smartphone
by touching the screen and swiping in
the up direction it will scroll down for
you but if you have an older control
there is a jump button here on our soft
keys when we use the jump we have the
ability to select last page and it jumps
to the end of the program right now it
doesn't hurt me to cursor down or one of
the other means of navigating the
control but as the program gets longer
that jump becomes a lot handier and more
Wow yeah it becomes easier to use the
jump button than it does some of the
other features let's call up our groove
tool anybody remember which what we did
to copy the the tool block we're gonna
highlight find our copy button highlight
all the way down we're gonna use the G
96 for this cycle because the groove
tool is going to be working on a
different diameter so we'll highlight
the whole thing and push our enter
button skip down to the end leave a line
so that we can separate our drill from
our groove do a paste and change our
data here again now our groove tool is
tool number four sheet 97 and 3's 1000
in number for T backbackback
404 I'm gonna omit the first two digits
because I'm not using a nose comp for
this and this is a point zero nine three
five
wide groove tool m8 that's good X 2.85
see point one that's just fine and let's
let's give it a little less on our
surface footage just so that we know
alright we did something different for
the groove we're positioned right in
front of the part
show me the part right here so I need to
move my tool from this clearance plane
to where I want to start the groove and
in my case I choose to start at this
back surface and work my way forward so
the first motion should be Z minus 0.38
zero that's this 200 thousands wide plus
the 180 of the lip and so that's where
my groove is gonna start I think I'd
like to leave a little bit for a finish
allowance so instead of being 380
let's take it to 378 so there'll be two
thousandths of clean up available on
this wall right here so now I've moved
into position there but I'm still all
the way up here above my raw stock so
let's make a wrap it down to something
that's closer to the 1.5 but obviously
not touching X let's go to 1.6 because I
just like that nice round number of
50,000th radial clearance now I'm ready
to call up my g73 cycle so show me g73
we've satisfied all of these guys and
we're ready to do our g73 very much like
the previous the G 74 cycle we need to
specify which cycle we're using our X
but now this is going to be the target
point previously we in the G 74 we
maintained the position the tool was in
but now we're doing the OD grooving so
we need to put our target point in there
which is one point three two five
1.3 to 5 however I do want to I do want
to leave a little bit on the finish so
let's take that 2 335 now we need a Z
target point our current position is 378
I want to make individual pecks
moving out in Z so our target point is
going to be minus one eight zero Z minus
point 180 oh let's give it a t2 so we
have the finish the amount of finish
that we had on the front and we want to
give it a K value which if we look up
here we'll see that the K is the shift
in the z axis that just means how far
over do we want to step see that K right
there how much do we want in between our
z axis pecs
we know that the tool that's oh 93 wide
so we want it to be less than that and
just so that our 2 lasts we'll make it
just a straight 50 thousandths now we
look over here and we see the D let's
use a D of 0.05 that means it's going to
Peck 50 thousands on the diameter each
time it moves in and then it's going to
retract and I also have I can't quite
see it but I have an e right here see
that e that he represents a dwell at the
bottom of the hole at the bottom of the
groove if I were not running a finish
pass I'd probably want the tool to dwell
there ever so slightly so that the
material will be cleaned up around 360
degrees of the periphery I'm gonna do
that just to say I did that's a little
light let's give it to one hundredths of
a second if you make that too much
you'll feel experience chatter at the
bottom of your groove you make it too
little and you won't quite have a
a completely cylindrical groove base now
we want to feed rate
let's give it say three thousands now
here is a concept that I did not talk
about yet and it may have lit off a red
flag in in your heads when I was looking
at my z-depth
I said that was Z point 380 - 380 and
this was Z minus 180 but wait a second
this face is being utilized by the front
of the groove tool and this is the back
of the groove tool oh jeez
well that could cause a problem but
Okuma has a way of compensating for this
if I add a t-value in my g73 cycle it
knows to use whatever tool offset is
currently active for the first part of
the cut but by the time it gets to the
end of the cut it'll use whatever offset
value I put in my tea
AHA that works that's clever as all
get-out now we're going to go through
and make sure that that's set up before
we verify this part so don't dwell on it
just know that we now have two offsets
for our groove tool the front is t0 for
offset four and the back is t0 for
offset 24 that way we have control over
the width of the groove as well as the
diameter and the location if we only use
one offset we still have location and
diameter adjustment but no width
adjustment
so that will terminate my g8 III cycle
just like the g7 I'm sorry g73 just like
the g7 t4 I like to give it a command to
move to a clearance plane just so that I
know it did I am well aware that the g7
t3 is supposed to deliver the tool back
to this location before it it terminates
the cycle but I like to be sure so there
we go X 1.6 now I roughed this groove
out I'm ready to finish that groove
let's do it with the same tool since
we're already in position I've moved out
to X 1.6 let's take the front edge of
the tool t zero four zero four and move
further in in Z then this minus 380
motion that we have right here so that
we can use our g76 corner round let's go
to Z minus 0.4 which is a good 20,000th
deeper than the then where the face will
be laid in and then we'll kick in to
feed mode and let's feed down to the 1.5
diameter that is the is the groove and
since we're not actually cutting
anything we'll move in a pretty good
clip there and then we will put in our
corner rounding function g76
and our terminal point is the minus
point three eight zero and L what's the
unnamed axis here it's X and our unnamed
axis is moving in the minus direction so
the L will be minus point zero one I
think ten thousandths is plenty to break
that edge don't you and then we'll give
it a nice slow feed rate so that my fill
it comes out pretty now I can finish
down that wall to the final diameter in
X which is x one point three two five
and let's let's go ahead and leave that
mm right where it is
I don't need to get get too crazy with
it
and now I'm ready to trace my tool along
this OD to finish up that guy so it's
going to be a Z move and I want to
terminate at minus point one eight zero
but I want to make sure that it's using
my secondary offset before it gets there
now I already know that there's two
thousand so on this wall and I don't
want to go run the tool into that
because it's gonna it's just not gonna
be happy so let's back this off by say
we'll make it 75 instead of minus 180 so
that means I'll be five fat whoops
that's the wrong way charlie y'all
almost caught me with a mistake so now
I've left five thousands here and I'm
gonna pop back out and do a little do a
little fill it action there my next move
I want to make a I'm just gonna kind of
pull the tool away from the wall here so
let's go to X one point 335 Z minus
point 190 so now I just made a little
angular move to get away from the wall
so that I can rapid G 0 to X one point
one point six get all the way out of the
hole following me so far we've got half
of this groove finished let's do the
other half now we're going to go follow
the same process and go Z minus well
let's go 160 because that's that's that
20,000th that we talked about we know
that our secondary offset is active
right now so I don't have to do anything
fancy there g12 x 1.5 that's our air cut
so we'll go a little faster then we'll
do our g76 radial move terminating at Z
minus 0.1 8 0 with our unnamed axis of
a negative point zero zero two and now
let's go down the wall to our minor
diameter which is x one point three to
five I'd like to make that little move
again and let's let's just retract
straight out do a little angular move X
1.3 35 by Z minus point 190 and let's
speed it up because we don't really need
to we don't really need to go slow right
there rap it out to our X of 1.6 to get
out of the groove and now I've roughed
and finished the front groove I am NOT
going to terminate this tool right now
because I would sure like to come up
here and cut out this this extra
material here I'm going to finish that
with the dnm g 55 degree tool but why
not I've got a groove tool in play
anyway why don't I just get rid of the
bulk of the material right there so that
the DN mg can work a little less hard so
I need to clear a little further than
1.6 let's take this guy all the way out
to above this diameter let's say 2.1
that will put us above this thread right
about here and so now i can wrap it all
the way back to my z minus 1.2 and in
keeping with my mm clearance that's
gonna put the thing a little further
forward and I can just do I don't need a
can cycle here I'm just gonna pop that
tool in there let's do a g1 to our ex
final diameter of 1.9 oh let's go 1 4 so
that we have our clearance and give it
an F on appropriate feed rate
let's go 2.85 all the way out whoops
there I did that that little mistake
without the X again at least I caught it
this time and now we can G 0 to X 30 Z
10 and an M 1 because we are completely
done with that tool everybody agree so
let's get rid of our print let's do our
selected quit go over to our operations
now as I promised I don't want to sit
here and make you guys watch this this
roughing tool every time we do a
verification so I'm going to bring my
program up here and I'm going to do a
restart by finding the restart key we're
still in machine lock so it's not
actually going to move but if I touch my
restart and I call up the sequence
number where I want to start in this
case n7 is it the first n7 or the second
n7 I want to read the modal value so I'm
going to use the first one and here is a
little note that even the guys that know
about sequence restart may not
understand do I want it to update the
graphics as it's going well yeah that
that's the whole reason I'm doing this
so we'll put it in effect and say ok as
soon as I hit OK it ran through the
program quickly as if it were physically
running and then stopped right where I
wanted to right where I wanted to start
my slow verification oh I started at the
insert drill my mistake no big deal
let's watch it in order to get the
machine to not give me an alarm during
restart I have to use this button right
here sequence restart right now and what
it will do is it will index the turret
two-putt put the previously used tool in
cutting position and place the turrets
where they would have been if I executed
the program normally up to this point
now I can hit cycle start and here comes
my drilling tool
did you do would have been nice fired
restarted it in four but you get the
point
there's my grooving cycle and there's my
finish uh-oh looks like I crunched I
didn't pull far enough out from the from
the material before I wrap it and my
collision avoidance software alerted me
to that that's that's kind of neat so
I'm gonna fix that let's reset everybody
we'll get back in here if you don't have
collision avoidance you and I both know
that two point one is greater than two
point zero and so you wouldn't have even
noticed that there's an alarm however I
like I like the collision avoidance
telling me hey that's that's closer than
I'm comfortable with so let's take this
out to two point two instead of two
point one that'll give me a full hundred
thousandths of clearance select and quit
auto mode now I'm going to pop in and
out of machine lock so that it resets my
turret and this time we'll do a restart
doo doo doo restart this time we'll use
the appropriate and for enter okay now
it wrap it it through the graphics and I
can push my restart button
give me my program doggone it dude there
it is all set to go cycle start groove
groove groove
and a finish and a finish ah it's still
angry why is it still angry I think I
just didn't move far enough out I'm
gonna fix this
a little Time Warp there I did a I fixed
it by moving the the total value out 2 x
2.5 that was enough to give full
clearance on the on that tool so that my
collision avoidance didn't interfere so
let's take a look at the full cycle
groove rough groove rough groove rough
groove fish groove finish wrap it out I
could probably put in another feed move
to make it go a little faster right
there but yeah either which way we now
came in and took a very slight amount of
material so now we have to oh you know
what I forgot to do I forgot to show you
the offset the double offset on this
thing so I went back to my tool data
page here and if you have the same
looking screen you notice that there are
two columns for offset one and one for
offset two this is the the location
where the machine decides where to send
data from the tool setter where to store
it for each individual tool I added four
and 24 and by just copying the
information from offset number four in
to offset 24 I was able to avoid having
to touch this tool twice if my tool set
over gauged properly I wouldn't have to
worry about this but on the Z I just
took the calibrated value from the front
of the tool and added minus the width of
the part off so 93 5 - 1103 is 203 eight
so now I have two offsets for that tool
and that's how I managed to get my
groove with an adjustable width
Wow that was a fun one wasn't it I think
we're ready to move on to the next does
everybody remember what the next process
is I don't so let's call up our process
list and see we did our turn we did our
drill we did our groove and now we're
ready for the finish turn wow that's
great because we really needed an easy
one to digest let's go back to our
program we'll edit let's go ahead and do
our copy function and our jump function
jump last page cursor up a few times
there's the end of our previous so we
can paste we know that our finishing
tool is number two so we'll change this
to two and change that to two because
we're using nose radius compensation in
the middle of this cycle we need to put
in our six digits this is now a dnm G
and it is a finish turn em eight deliver
to position call up our spindle we're
good to go let's look at our sheet for
the two axis process G 87 moved
clearance cutting position spindle
commands we've done everything call
cycle referring to profile and there is
our our little format this is incredibly
easy G 87 is my finishing cycle and now
I simply need to specify what what is
the definition sequence if you recall it
was n 80 and it was our first one so n
80 0 1 now the book shows you that you
can have a U and a W in here if you like
too
have a finish allowance in your G 87 but
why would you finish allowance a finish
allowance hmm you can if you say you
want to make this a semi finish tool but
in our case a as soon as we do this
we're done and I didn't have to redefine
that entire profile because it's already
written in n 8001 so once we're finished
we will G 0 to X 30 Z 10 give us the M 1
and let's run the let's run the program
all the way through shall we there's our
cycle slam we're gonna do our roughing
tool give me my program doggone it
there's our finish our roughing pass and
previously I told you that to watch this
this surface finish on the graphic it
knows that we're in a high feed rake
right now so it's showing it kind of
rough when we do a finish it's going to
smooth that out which is just really all
it's handy as all get-out pop my drill
with the intermediate retract and it's
also if you notice when this drill comes
out it's utilizing a different color for
each of the tools that are cutting which
also makes it very handy if you have a
gouge or something a feature in your
part you're not sure which tool is doing
it this color is a great indication of
what's going on now there's our
finishing tool notice that it smooths
out
the the roughing contour because hey
it's moving in a much slower feed rate
and zip across the front I probably
should have sped that up in my n 8001
but I'll do that on my time so that the
next time we verify this it doesn't take
so much time but now we're done it
delivers the part back to our clearance
plane and that it's going to send it
home and we're done so now we have
roughed we have drilled we've grooved we
finished and we're ready to move on to
the next process and that next process
is threading we're ready to do the
threading cycle let's call it up we know
that this is a 2-inch by 12 threads per
inch and our major and minor diameter is
listed right here and we have the
document for g71 where we're going to
see what the machine is asking for plus
a whole bunch of little optional extras
that we can throw in while we're making
a thread we'll describe those in just a
second but let's go back in and take a
look at our program we're gonna go
program edit we'll do our tool call copy
and paste again let's use that guy just
to say we did we'll copy him
and bring him down to the bottom paste
him in now let's change our values to
the appropriate tool and three and we're
gonna do say will do 1800 rpm on this
guy as I'm typing I'll tell you that one
of the biggest mistakes I see people
doing while they're doing single-point
threading is they're just turning too
darn slow it is true that you if you run
too fast the Machine can't keep up with
the a cell D cell the inertia the
momentum all of the the physics factors
that are affecting the Machine but also
to slow is going to cause the material
to gall and it's going to give us a
pretty nasty pretty nasty surface finish
so let's keep this let's keep this at
about 1800 rpm and and we'll know that
we have the ability to pump it up if we
need to just so that we get that that
tool coasting smoothly through the
material instead of ripping and tearing
and we'll call up our g71 cycle so that
we can see we've done all of this
information and now we are ready to call
our cycle
g71 is our cycle and let's see the
values that we need here we need an X is
e and H a D well let's let's talk about
each one of them the first is the X and
that's our target point that's not where
we are now that's where the minor
diameter of the thread will wind up
being so in our case our engineer was
nice enough to already give us the minor
diameter of the thread there it is so we
will put in X 1.8 9 3 and a Z which is
the target value again and so we're
terminating into a thread relief here so
it really doesn't matter exactly where
we stopped as long as we don't go so far
as to smack into this this wall right
here we don't want the tool to gouge for
us so let's make the Z minus 1 point say
to 10 that should be enough to get all
the way through a complete thread in the
last but not smack into this wall here
the next value that we need need is a D
let's go ahead and look at that cycle
again it doesn't matter what order we
put them in as long as we get all of our
values in here the D is the depth of cut
of the first thread expressed as a
diameter so let's put in D point 0 1 and
allow me to explain that that's the
depth of the first pass depending on
some of the cut conditions that we will
specify at the end of this this cycle
that depth of cut may decrease as it
gets down to the bottom of the of the
thread helps to eliminate chatter in a
lot of case and extends our tool life
but by saying a do point 0 1 it's never
going to increase above that D value
right there the the next value we'll
want to put in is au value this is a
finish allowance for the x-axis we're
going to the g71 will ruff and finish
for us so this you will be taken out
during some finished passes not a
problem for us next value is an H
if you look at your list the H is a
thread height expressed as a diameter so
our thread height due to - - is major -
minor and we would divide it by two but
because our H is expressed as a
diametrical value we don't have to let's
just go ahead and say that this is a
hundred thousandths thread height now I
am NOT going to let's let's make that a
little smaller so that I can tell you
what it is that I'm doing here this H is
a negotiable value it doesn't have to be
exact
the machine is utilizing this H value to
dictate where the first pass is going to
occur it takes this X target and adds
the H and that's where it's going to
make the first pass so if you if you
make this number larger that first pass
is going to be lighter you're still
going to finish at X 1.8 93 which is
going to establish the pitch diameter of
your thread that's the only factor that
matters here's our pitch diameter it's
not going to change that value so if
that first pass turns out to be too
heavy
we'll make our H larger if the first
pass is too light we can eight make the
H smaller and it will it'll dig a little
deeper on the first pass now we need a
feed rate which is 1 divided by threads
per inch and in our case that's 0.08 e33
1 divided by 12 is point O 833 there's
our thread pitch and now we're gonna
throw in a couple of em codes to let the
machine know the type of pattern we want
to use now let's talk about these real
quick
we know that a threading tool has a
cutting edge on the front and the back
of the tool 1 is plus 30 degrees one's
minus 30 degrees but if you're cutting
equally on both of those faces
you can cause undue tool pressure and
some chatter this can cycle gives us the
ability to say you know what don't cut
with both faces by moving in a tool
pattern like what you see illustrated
here each subsequent pass will go
forward in Z by the amount that you've
pulled in divided by you know
Pythagorean theorem the 30-degree angle
and so it will always be cutting with
the front edge of the tool we can also
make it stagger so the first pass will
be using this cutting edge then it will
move to the front cutting edge then the
back cutting edge front back front back
all the way down so that provides equal
tool wear and then we can also specify
whether we want that that infeed cutting
pattern to be equal cutting depth all
the way down or if we want it to
automatically reduce as it gets towards
the bottom so I happen to be a big fan
of this cutting pattern in steel so
let's use it right there it tells us m33
m73 so if I come in here at the end of
my line and say m 33 M 73 now I know
that it'll make this cutting pattern as
it goes down towards the bottom of the
of the thread I don't have to do
anything else for my threading pattern
so let's just take the tool home X 30 Z
10 M 1 and we'll take a look at what it
looks like get rid of all this stuff
we'll do our select and quit yes
and that was in three so let's do a
restart at in three enter make sure our
graphic is in effect so it'll go fast
through all of this stuff subdued to two
and now we'll use our turn on our
program of course and use our sequence
restart and cycle start here comes our
tool and it's making our cut pass now
obviously in the graphics I can't see it
excuse me even when it's physically
cutting in a machine you can't really
see it staggering left and right using
the both of the the cutting edges but
you'll see it in the result over using a
straight pattern so now I have rough
drill thread and groove I'm ready to
move on to the next evolution and the
next evolution on our process list is to
deburr the thread now this is pretty
self-explanatory but let's beat a dead
horse shall we
when I run this threading tool through
this material even though I'm using that
staggered pattern that you saw it's
gonna be a little cobby at the crests
we're gonna have some burrs on the OD of
the thread nothing a little scotch-brite
wouldn't take off but this is a dynamite
machine so why not deburr everything
inside the machine plus I also know that
it's gonna roll a burr right on this
front edge and one in the back too plus
we haven't even finished that thread
relief so what I intend to do is to take
my finish turning tool and eliminate
this burr skim across the OD of the part
to get rid of those burrs on top of the
thread and then chase out this thread
relief so let's do that go into my
program edit and since I am reutilizing
one of the tools I've already used why
don't I just go to that evolution
there it is DN mg finish and we will
copy that process and paste its
preliminaries I also like to clarify my
sequence number if I'm using a tool more
than once in this case n2 was already
used up here it's not going to generate
an alarm by any means but I'd like the
clarity when I'm running to know that
it's the first time to use the tool it's
the second time so forth and so on so I
like to add the n/a and that way I know
that okay this tool has been used before
this is a second time I'm calling it up
and everybody everybody will be on the
same page all of my other information is
going to remain the same and there is no
cycle really that will help me with
doing this this little contour right
here we already know that the N 8001
does a profile that will finish this guy
and this guy but it won't touch this
surface so rather than repeat the n 8001
I'm just going to use this tool and
trace this little feature right here so
that there's not going to be any
additional cutting here that could
potentially cause chatter let's just do
a point to point in order to keep my
life simple let's find my OD print here
and have it ready so that I can give my
my point to point for my actual profile
so I'm up in front and I would like to
wrap it to a position that is somewhere
down around here let's not waste time
feeding across the front so I will say
we're gonna go to X of 1 point 9 9 5
that's still a decent clearance plane Z
minus point 4 and that was in rapid so I
don't want to
I don't want to encroach on the part at
this point that's why I'm still a goodly
little distance away from it
but now I can drop below this value here
and let's just call this X one point
seven seven five so that I have enough
to use the g76 do a straight line move
and cut this recut that little angle
there so we will now shift into g1 mode
and specify that we're gonna do the G
whoops not a radius we want the 75
chamfer we're gonna wind up at X 1 point
9 9 5 and a an l-value
of the unnamed axis Z minus point O 7 5
and give it a feed rate of like go say
mm or so now I did not utilize my my
cutter compensation here and I should
have and I also have forgotten to move
in in my Z to the 1/2 inch so that was a
little bit of a mistake let's go G 1 Z
minus 0.5 and g42 and we'll make that a
pretty decent feed rate okay so now we
moved in and turned on our cutter
compensation didn't forget it this time
made our move out to the edge of the
part and now we will make a Z move to
right about here so let's go Z minus oh
let's call that 1.04 ish because it
should be the one 250 minus the 110 and
then the champers so ya 1.04 should be
pretty good and we'll give it a little
bit faster feed rate since all we're
doing is deburring now let's move to our
minor the bottom of the groove the X one
point 904 not oh nine T 4
one point 904 and because we want to cut
this angle in the back I also want to
make the Z move to our one point 250 -
110 so we'll make that Z minus one point
one four and use our decreased feed rate
and the final move Z minus one point two
five and then we will now we're up
against this face we can move straight
out to our g40 cancel the nose radius
compensation go out to X so let's go to
something well above where our material
is now we can G zero let's go back out
to our clearance plane so that we're not
doing a two axis near the part and then
we'll G 0 to X 30 z10 just like we
always do m1 see how we did and minimize
there's our operation and let's do a
restart at our in a - okay as it's
zipping I'm going to turn my program on
now I'll do my sequence restart and do
my cycle slam there goes my finish tool
cutting just the burrs off of the part
yep there we go
so now we've just deburred our threads
but there's a pretty good chance that we
could have rolled that burr especially
if our tool starts getting dull rolled
that burr back into the thread lead so
let's just run that threading tool one
more time through the through the thread
lead in order to make sure that that's
clean so we're kind of chasing our tail
we threaded then we finished and now
we're gonna thread again but hey no big
deal we want that thread lead to be good
so let's just take our entire process
here and we'll copy it and we'll bring
it down below our deeper of the thread
and we'll paste it change that to an a
three and a three and everything else
could remain the same but I will find
out the hard way that this original
thread path made about nine passes we
don't need that anymore
we only need one or two to clear through
so let's change this D value to
something something large and I think
that might be too much but let's see
what happens if I were to restart at in
a what was that that was three right so
in a three
- - and when I say it might be too large
but we'll find out mathematically the
the depth of cut cannot be greater than
the the thread height - the my I'm sorry
added to the minor so if it does turn
out to be too much we're gonna get an
alarm up looked like it was just fine in
fact I probably could have gone a little
more because it gave us seven passes
instead of the original mine but no big
deal
I'm happy with it it doesn't take that
long and now we have a nice threaded
part that's deburred and finished and
we're ready to move on to the next
operation so let's take a look at our
process list again wave now D bird and
rethread so now we're ready to do the
boring cycle now the bore is just going
to be a rehash of our g85 cycle so let's
grab any tool call copy that and jump
down to the bottom and re paste it and
now we can change our values - to our
boring bar which we decided was tool
number eight
[Music]
change it to eight we'll use our nose
radius comp on this so 808 Oh
eight-eight this time we don't need to
go to a clearance plane that's above our
our material stock we actually want to
go below the material stock and position
the tool at the inverse of the clearance
plane of where our drill is so
previously we were going to a hundred
thousandths above our material stock and
we know we just popped a 747 hole in
there so let's go to an X of 0.7 oh yeah
if we did 750 let's go 650 for our our
clearance plane on the boring bar and
we'll let's let's pump this up it's
probably gonna run up against our rev
limiter because we're working on the
inside of the part but hey whatever
we're happy we're just following along
with the manufacturer's specifications
and we will repeat our g85 cycle at this
point this time our na T is going to be
the second definition cycle so there is
our n 8002 and we already know about
leaving a finish allowance in X I
finished allowance in Z and a depth of
cut yeah let's go seventy-five
thousandths and a roughing feed rate and
we'll give it something a little less
than the then the turning tool since a
boring bar is never going to be as rigid
as this this time an eighty zero to our
shape definition we're also going to do
a G eighty one cycle just like we did
before but this time our G zero is going
to be out and above our finished
diameter again we're wrapping out this
time for our positioning move so this is
how the machine is going to decide that
we're doing an ID and it will leave our
finish allowance on the minus side of
the wall so our first move should wrap
it out above our final diameter so let's
go to X one point
oh let's do something like 275 275 and
then we can do our G 1 G 41 since we're
on the opposite side of the part this
time and z0 at an F of Y and let's go
5,000 where we can move it a pretty good
clip here now let's break the edge here
as well we might as well deburr that so
let's use our g76 edge breaking cycle
put in our final diameter and our el
unnamed axis is Z and that's gonna move
in the minus direction and since it's
not called out let's just put in a
little 10,000 sej break there just to
say we did give it an appropriate feed
rate now we'll just continue on with our
profile z minus 0.1 20 is the depth of
this bore now we do have a called out
50,000 spy 45 so we can use our G 75
sharing cycle our final diameter is X
point 750 and our unnamed axis the Z is
moving at 50 thousandths in the minus
direction and let's we forgot to
increase the feed right there but then
we'll shift it down for our two axis
motion that's good and now we'll just go
down to our final depth which will be Z
minus one point two five zero and just
as I did in the previous the OD cycle I
want to deliver the tool back to this
the X point 650 so cancel our nose
radius compensation X 0.65 zero just as
I did before and then reference G 80 as
being the end of the profile cycle since
we're roughing and finishing with the
same tool I don't have to do anything
like sending the tool home at this point
I can simply tell it hey G 87 let's do
our finish cycle and it's the definition
of an 80 0 2 now I will
follow my safety protocol and get the
tool further away from the part just so
I see my motion and then go home to X 30
z10 and m1 ready to take a shot at it
select and quit yes let's get rid of our
print here and I will once again do a
restart this time we're going to n8 okay
and while it's doing that I'll call up
my program let it go through quickly
then we will do the sequence restart and
cycle start there goes our boring bar
doing exactly what we wanted and our
finished bass now let's talk about a
couple of the little hidden features and
the graphics that are gonna help us out
we couldn't see what the bottom of the
board looked like so graphics is going
to help us out in a couple of ways I
could turn on my section which then cuts
away the part and now I can see what the
bar looked like or the bore looked like
I could also if the section isn't making
me happy I could turn on this
transparent right here that's a little
more difficult to see but you can
certainly tell now I'm gonna run that
one more time just time with the section
off so that we can see the bore itself
do its business as long as I have the
the section view on it'll run through
with the the part cut away now I can see
exactly what the boring bar is doing
Scheffer the edge break and the finish
bore sighs it came out of the hole as it
should and now I've got my bore complete
so now I've completed my entire part and
I'm ready to cut the thing off let's
turn our section back off and we'll
program the part off tool and then we'll
run the whole thing in graphics so that
we can see the entire evolution of our
effort all combined into one process
let's do another double check of our
process list we've done turn drill
groove finish turn thread DeBary thread
bore and now we're set to cut off the
final evolution of the part we've
covered a lot of stuff haven't we all
right so let's edit this time I'm gonna
retype everything for the the part off
tool just don't for no apparent reason
other than I feel like doing a little
refresher we have the sequence number
that matches our tool number and 12 G
zero for the rapid g95 for inches per
revolution programming G 97 for constant
rpm and let's fire this up at s 1000
then we'll call up our tool T 1212 and
I'm not using nose radius compensation
so I don't need the extra digits cut off
blade and an m8 for coolant let's move
to our X 2.85 by 0.1 even though that's
not where we're gonna use the tool
that's a nice clearance plane and now
I'm gonna repeat the G 50 previously we
were using 2727 50 as our maximum rpm
but in this case I don't want to go that
fast we're about to make the part pretty
fragile it's just gonna be hanging on by
a little bit and I don't want the
spindle ramping up all the way to 20 750
as this thing starts to separate so
let's knock that down to say
g50 of s 1500 that'll be a lot easier to
manage and will give our G 96 are
constant spindle speed to OS 400 that
should be enough to keep our part off
blade in good condition so now let's
let's look at our our part and
strategize what we're gonna do here I'd
like to break this edge we're gonna cut
part off to the finished allowance we're
going to assume that we're not going to
try to reach up this part and finish
this face now we know that you have to
have a really high-quality part off tool
to do this because if you do part it off
right at two and a half inches if that
part off blade isn't making a clean
surface on the backside then we're gonna
have to face this off in a second
operation anyway but let's let's ignore
that for now and just assume that we
have a really high quality part off
blade and we're following some good
strategy so we're gonna we're gonna part
this off as a finished part so I would
like to break that edge and if I just
plunge in with my part off tool
obviously that's gonna be a nice sharp
corner at best and it'll be a big ragged
burr at the worst so I'd like to take my
part off tool and cut a little bit of an
edge break on that however if I do that
in one shot as the tool makes contact
with the material while it's
transitioning here I'm gonna go from
zero to pressure zero tool contact here
and as I swing that radius or my chamfer
I'm gonna go from 0% cutter engagement
to a hundred percent while I'm
interpolating the the radius that's
that's not good so my strategy is to
come out here go beyond the 2.5 and
plunge in to make a little relief back
here then I can swing that fill it
without having all kinds of excessive
tool pressure so what we'll do is make
that relief then we'll pop back out and
we'll make that cut then I'm gonna use
my g73 pecking cycle to clear down until
we get oh let's say 250,000 s we'll
leave a quarter-inch of material that
will maintain the connection between the
finished part and our bar stock then
we're gonna shift into a slow g1 and
just knock that thing off into our parts
catcher wow that's a lot but we can do
it it's not that big a deal so let's
start by wrapping from our current
clearance plane to where we want to make
our relief so let's go to Z - two point
six three five I am not using two
offsets for this cutoff blade you can
that certainly we already know how to do
it we saw it in the groove pattern but I
also want to demonstrate how you can do
this by computing the math yourself
instead of the double axis thing the the
double offset thing so I went to two
point five plus the 125 part off groove
part off to a width and then added
another ten thousandths just to swing
that relief so now I've gone to X two
point two point six thirty-five I'll
shift into feed mode g1 and then I'll
just plunge the part to say oh let's go
- I'm gonna go to two point five at a
fast feed and then I'll slow down and go
to say X two point four that's something
a lot slower that way I'm getting
through the air a little faster and we
probably should make that ten
thousandths of the parts so that we we
don't get bit by a tool that's gauged a
little a little bit off so now I've
plunged in and I want to wrap it back
out of the part because now I've made my
relief and I'm ready to swing my radius
so let's bring this to X two point six
and we will move the front edge of the
tool back a little bit in Z so that we
can swing our radius let's go to Z minus
2.5 75 because that is again still
gauging by the front of the tool so we
want to take where our position is and
factor out the width of the groove tool
so 2.5 75 should be plenty for that
shift back into feed mode and now let's
feed down to the major diameter of the
part x 2.5 you may want to add a little
bit here but I'm gonna go with perfect
world and imagine that 2.5 is not going
to touch the part if your part off blade
is gauged perfectly then may we won't we
won't make any kind of cut on the OD of
the part now I can use my G 76 and go to
my final length of the part Z minus 2
point 6 to 5
I better make that a minus that would
suck now our unnamed axis is the X so we
will do an L of - and let's put in a
20,000 fill it there and a nice modest
feed rate of f2 now we're sitting right
about here and as we discussed a minute
ago let's use our canned cycle g73 OD
grooving and peck it down to about a
quarter inch so X target not 2.5 0.25
there we go and our Z is going to
maintain at Z - 2 point 6 to 5 and we'll
use a depth of let's go a quarter inch
depth of cut and my L at this time I
don't need to pull the tool all the way
out so I'm going to make the L value
greater than the distance traveled let's
just say Oh
of 2.5 is the dynamic yeah let's just
say L of 2.5 so it'll short retract
throughout the entire process and we'll
give it a feed rate point zero zero
three so after it swings this it is
going to it's going to make the Peck
down to two point three but then it's
going to return back up to here and I
just looked up and noticed that I did
something that I told you I couldn't do
I just tried to terminate with the g76
without another linear move can't do it
so let's go
X two point four so that now it will
it'll have a straight line move after
the fill it good thing I saw that so we
know that after the g73 performs it's
going to wrap it all the way back out to
the the major of the part and I don't
want to I don't want to wrap it back in
on the off chance that this thing
Wiggles a little bit so I'm gonna do a
g1 a terminal of X point so let's go to
75 something above where I was here so I
don't come crunching back into material
but I'll give it a faster feed rate
because we're just positioning here all
I'd all I'm trying to avoid is a rapid
causing this part to wiggle a little bit
pinch my part off tool in the cut and
caused some catastrophic issues now that
I've rapid it in I'm ready to deploy my
parts catcher now some of you may ask
well why didn't you deploy your parts
catcher in the beginning of the program
or I'm starting at the beginning of the
program but the beginning of this part
off tool in case the part separates
during this well for one I'm counting on
it not separating but for two if I
deployed the parts catcher somewhere up
here that means all of the chips that
were generated in this process so far
are now
in my parts catcher yeah and when the
parts catcher retracts its gonna dump
all those chips into my bucket and I
really don't need that so why not allow
all these chips to fall down into the
chip conveyer and then deploy my parts
catcher I'm ready to deploy it now so
let's look at our M code process and
find where our parts catcher is there it
is M 77 for advanced M 76 for retreat so
let's just get in here and put in M 77
and I'm gonna put a note in there you
don't have to but I like to put that
little note so that I am reminded of
what M 77 is cuz I'm chronic for
forgetting that stuff now that the parts
of catcher is deployed I'm going to g1
and go over centerline with the part off
tool at a feed rate that is slower than
normal so I don't leave a big
abnormality on the backside yeah let's
let's make that go down to one by the
way at this point if I wanted to which
in this case yeah hey I would sure like
to do this I can shift cut conditions
I've been using G 76 I'm sorry G 96
constant surface speed up to this point
but now we're only cutting off a little
bit so I could shift and say hey now
let's do G 97 s 800 which is a lot
slower rpm than we would have been going
and so what I'm trying to achieve here
is to reduce the the speed the
revolutions that the part is rotating as
it separates I don't want this thing
spinning at 2,000 rpm as it drops into
the catcher bucket because then it can
utilize that rotation to spin itself out
of the bucket and yeah I don't want to
do that so now I have slowed down my rpm
to 800 I'll make my final cut that
should drop the part in the bucket I can
then move myself out of the cut now I
always do it in X back to my clearance
back to a clearance plane just because I
don't know if the part off blade will
have completely separated this part and
if I try to make a retraction move
that's two axis or in Z first I can
damage my part off blade so I would just
as soon retract straight out and then do
my M whoops mmm 76 which is catcher
retract which will dump the part into my
my bucket and then I can G 0 to X 30 z10
and I don't need an M 1 here because
that is the end of my program let's get
rid of some of these extra line spaces
and have it terminate right here all
right so let's do our select and quit
yes get rid of our print and now let's
verify this from the very beginning so
that we can see the whole thing right
now we believe we're finished with the
part and so let's watch the entire
process from the get-go it may take a
little bit of time but heck it's fun
right our roughing tool using the N 8001
roughing cycle we remember that there's
our drill using the G 70 for short
retract combined combined with full
retract
now we've got our groove tool doing a
little step over an edge break on our
groove throw in a relief finishing tool
that's taking out all the the rough that
was left over from the original and 8001
now our part is at finished diameter and
should have nice surface finish on the
the two axis moves as well as the single
axis threading tool comes back in and
does the does the thread to final
diameter then we'll call up our DN mg
again and this time just deeper the
thread the thread lead and thread relief
now we'll come back in and reach ace the
thread so that our lead is intact and
our mating part will fit properly
there's our boring bar roughing and now
the boring bar finishing and it will go
all the way home there's our relief cut
there's our edge break now we're gonna
go into the short retract pecking cycle
there's our G 83 and this sorry G 73
down to 250 now it pulled all the way
back out fast fed back in parts catcher
deployed and it separated the part it's
gonna go pretty slow they're retracted
out of the groove and there's our
completed part I'm going to use my angle
change feature
and we'll turn this thing there we go
and we will I like to see anytime I
change the angle it erases the entire
graphic so let's do a restart at in 12
so that we can see that the part off
blade really did go all the way through
to the to completely separate the part
there's our sequence restart and our
cycle slam
there's the relief there's the edge
break
there's our pecking cycle every
quarter-inch it's retracting ever so
slightly just enough to break a chip and
now at left quarter-inch we fed back in
quickly shift it into 800 rpm and
separated the part wrap it out we're
done
alrighty then the only thing left to do
is to physically run the part in the
machine now obviously I don't have a
machine connected to this but I'm gonna
use my collision avoidance software and
show you a couple of the ways to
manipulate the fancy programming that we
put in there the first of which that I
want to mention is the the clearance
planes that we talked about remember how
I always went go to the major OD plus a
hundred thousandth or fifty on the
radius and a 0.1 so what I'm gonna do
here to show you how that works is I'm
gonna slow down this is exactly what I
would do on a real real machine and then
turn on my single block so that I can
one at a time
hit cycle start watch it
you know spool up so things don't get
out of control there we're doing a
thousand rpm
there's my tool call it pulled up my
first tool and then it's going to turn
on the coolant and you notice now soup
I watched it slowly come down probably
standing there with my hand on the feed
hold button and just wanted to make sure
that it really stopped above the OD and
in front of the face of the part
let's angle that a little bit so that
you can see that yeah well okay
alright we're in front of the part we're
off to the side we're good to go once I
see that happen now I know that the tool
gauging is good and the only other thing
I'm gonna worry about during this
because I've already proven the cycle
works and graphics is I need to watch
and make sure this tool is not going to
go so far back as to clip the jaws so I
will take my feed rate back up to what
it's supposed to be now I can take off
my single block and hit the cycle slam
button
there's my facing move I feel
comfortable with that and now right
about now I'm standing there with my
hand on the feed hold button to make
sure that nothing contacts the jaws up
looks good after that first pass is done
I'm confident so I can just let this
thing run now for those of you that
aren't familiar with the collision
avoidance software you'll notice that
hey wait a second the blank is reducing
its size before my tool gets there yeah
the collision avoidance is doing that it
is looking two blocks ahead of what's
physically running right now just to
make sure that the collision is detected
before it actually starts the the motion
that would cause the crash so I skipped
over I left my single block off but I
would do that with each tool the the
single block approach just to make sure
that things are working the way they're
supposed to we're about to
kick into our thread this is our
finished pass and it's taking its own
sweet time I'm going to do the single
block again so that we can talk a little
bit when the boring bar comes up but
there's my threading cycle and then we
will have the thread deeper
and chase the thread I turned on single
block just now so that you could see the
characteristics if you haven't
experienced this in a threading cycle
single block is kind of neat because
every time you hit the cycle start
button it'll make another pass on the
thread so this way you can walk through
and if you're not confident that you're
not going to kiss the back wall or
something okay so now we're going to do
our roughing tool I'm going to go back
to showing you what I my feed rate
overrides single block on and the the
reason I wanted to do this with a boring
bar is so that you could see each time
you hit the cycle start button go faster
charlie go faster it executes another
branch of the turning can cycle
and then as soon as that's done I'm
going to let's take off the single block
I'll see if I can catch it on the finish
pass so I wanted you to see though to do
looks like we'll do one more and now
we're on our finished pass there it is
there's the bottom now this is the this
is the condition I was talking about a
couple of times about a boring bar doing
a one axis retract instead of two we're
at the bottom of our hole right now if I
hit cycle start that single block moved
it to the X 650 diameter remember we put
that in there to match the approach
diameter and the reason is for this guy
right here when I push cycle start to
get retracted straight out single z
motion if that X if the final X does not
match the initial X you'll see a two
axis motion and in general that's enough
to scare you to death not my not my idea
of fun so there's our cutoff blade we do
our relief we do the edge break let's
crank this up because it does take a
couple of seconds you notice that our
spindle rpm is just gradually raising
that's that G 96 thing and as soon as
that's done we pull it out move back in
a quick feed rate there's our parts
catcher deploying we're moving down
across X centerline fairly slowly the
part would have fallen into the bucket
bucket what it dumped it out looks like
we did it right